TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE CODE NINETEEN
OR MERGING CITY AND TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE STATE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO SHORT TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES. TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
HOLDING TODAY'S COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL
UTILIZING THE STATE SENATE
CHAMBER TO ALLOW FOR
APPROPRIATE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
WITH SUMMER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PHYSICALLY PRESENT. AND SOME
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY WE
HAVE TWO MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY CENTER ANDREAS
BORCHERS AND SENATOR MONIQUE
LIMON IN THE SENATE CHAMBER
WITH ME THIS MORNING ARE CENTER
LEANING AND SALAS CENTER MIKE
MCGUIRE SENATOR RICHARD PAN AND
SENATOR RICHARD ROTH WE WILL
HAVE A NUMBER OF SPEAKERS WITH
US TODAY WERE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. I WILL
PROVIDE A BRIEF INTRODUCTION
FOR EACH OF THEM AT THE OPENING
OF EACH OF THE HEARINGS THREE
PANELS FOR A REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONE SUPPORT COMPUTERS. THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I'D ALSO
ASK THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
BE RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PLACE YOU BACK ON MUTE%
WHEN YOU WERE DONE. TO ENSURE
PUBLIC ACCESS FOR TODAY'S
HEARING WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL
ALSO BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. REMOTELY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROMOTE
BUT PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE ARE POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AS I ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FIVE TWO SIX FOUR ZERO
ZERO THREE AGAIN FIVE TWO- SIX
FOR. ZERO ZERO THREE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE.
ANDORRA COMMITTEE WEBSITES. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE HEARING
FROM ALL OF THE PANELISTS ON
THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES WILL
HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT
ON THE TOPICS. ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY INTO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE ON WHICH YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING. PRIOR TO
GIVING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. AS CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE ARE WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS. WHILE EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS WHILE
CONDUCTING OUR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. AND WILL
BEGIN. THE UNITED STATES
REMAINS ONE OF THE ONLY
DEVELOPED COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE
FREE CARE FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
AMONG ITS OTHER AFFECTS THE
PANDEMIC IT SHINED A BRIGHT
LIGHT ON HOW A LACK OF CHILD
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE FURTHER
DEVASTATES FAMILIES AND
EXACERBATES THE STRESSORS
FACING PARENTS ESPECIALLY
MOTHERS ESPECIALLY WORKING
MOTHERS AS CALIFORNIA AND THE
REST OF THE NATION CONTINUE TO
GRAPPLE WITH THE CHALLENGES OF
THE CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC CHILD
CARE HAS BEEN AMONG THE HARDEST
HIT IN LEE SUPPORTED OF ALL
SECTORS WITHIN THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY. WELL BEFORE THE ONSET
OF THE CURRENT CRISIS
CALIFORNIA'S PARENTS HAVE LONG
STRUGGLE TO FIND IN FOR CHILD
CARE THAT MEETS THEIR NEEDS AND
CHILD CARE BUSINESSES HAVE
EQUALLY STRUGGLE TO BALANCE THE
COST OF PROVIDING QUALITY
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
CARE WITH THE LIMITED REVENUES
AVAILABLE TO THEM THE PANDEMIC
HAS EXACERBATED THESE EXISTING
CHILD CARE. ISSUES WHILE
RAISING SIGNIFICANT NEW
CHALLENGES WHICH WE WILL HEAR
MORE ABOUT THE IN TODAY'S
HEARING DURING THE PANDEMIC
MANY CHILD CARE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO CLOSE SOME FOR A
PERIOD OF TIME AND OTHERS
PERMANENTLY WILLMANY OF SINCE
WE OPENED THE A FOUND
THEMSELVES OPERATING WITH
DECREASED ENROLLMENT AND
INCREASED INSTABILITY DUE TO
THE ONGOING IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. THIS NEW REALITY
POSES A DIRE THREAT TO MANY
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS WHICH WERE
ALREADY OPERATING ON RAZOR THIN
MARGINS AND LACKED THE
FINANCIAL RESERVES TO WEATHER
NORMALLY HE COULD NORMAL
ECONOMIC DOWNTURNS MUCH LESS
SOMETHING AS PROFOUND AS THE
RECESSION CAUSED BY THE
PANDEMIC WHAT THE CARES ACT
PASSED BY CONGRESS IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY PROVIDE STATES
PROVIDED STATES WITH THREE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE CHILD CARE DEVELOPMENT
BLOCK GRANT. TO SUPPORT ACCESS
TO CHILDCARE THIS LEVEL OF
FUNDING HAS PROVEN INSUFFICIENT
TO MEET THE NEED ESPECIALLY AS
THE PANDEMIC HAS STRETCHED ON
MEANWHILE CHILD CARE BUSINESSES
HAVE DONE THEIR BEST TO
CONTINUE TO ASSERT TO SERVE THE
CHILDREN OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND OTHERS WHO RELY ON SHELVE
CHILD CARE IN ORDER TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE WORK FORCE
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH WITHOUT
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL INVESTMENT
HALF OF AMERICA'S CHILD CARE
CAPACITY IS CURRENTLY AT RISK
OF EXPOSURE. THIS WOULD HAVE A
CATASTROPHIC IMPACT ON THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY JEOPARDISING
THOUSAND CHILDCARE JOBS LEAVING
MILLIONS OF CHILDREN WITHOUT
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE AND
PLUNGING PARENTS. EMPLOYERS
FURTHER INTO TURMOIL AS THEY
CAN TO YOU TO JUGGLE WORK AND
FOR. WERE DESPITE THE CRITICAL
ROLE CHILD CARE AND SUPPORTING
ECONOMY THERE IS A LACK OF
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING AS TO WHAT
IT REALLY COSTS. AND WHAT IT
TRULY ENTAILS TO PROVIDE
QUALITY CHILDCARE PARTICULAR
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS FACE NEW
GUIDELINES AND CHALLENGES. IN
RESPONDING TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMICS. THE GOAL
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO EXAMINE
SOME OF THESE ISSUES IN DEPTH
ACROSS A WIDE VARIETY
PERSPECTIVES. FROM EXPERTS
PARTICIPANTS IN THE FIELD WITH
THE GOAL OF STARTING A MUCH
NEEDED CONVERSATION. ABOUT NOT
ONLY HOW TO BETTER ADDRESS
ISSUES AS WE MAKE OUR THREE OUR
WAY THROUGH THE RESOLUTION. OF
THE CURRENT CRISIS BUT HOW TO
DEVISE BETTER POLICIES AND
SOLUTIONS MOVING FORWARD ONES
THAT WILL NOT ONLY BENEFIT
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING FAMILIES.
AND THE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
SUPPORTING THEM WHAT ARE THE
KEYS TO A BETTER LIFE AND A
MORE DYNAMIC CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
AS WELL. BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
OUR SPEAKERS ARE WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN NOW.
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE THIS
ACCESS CODE. FIVE TWO SIX FOUR
ZERO ZERO THREE AGAIN ACCESS
CODE IS FIVE TWO SIX FOUR ZERO
ZERO THREE. I WILL NOW TURN TO
OUR FIRST PANEL TO DISCUSS THE
PRESSURES THAT ARE CHARACTERS
SYSTEM HAS COME UNDER DURING
THE EARLY STAGES. OF THE
PANDEMIC. OUR FIRST PANELIST
WILL BE JULIE MORE AN IN HOME
CHILDCARE PROVIDER AND A MEMBER
OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS UNITED.
WHO SPEAK TO HOW THE PANDEMIC
HAS IMPACTED YOUR BUSINESS.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM DAVID AS
BEEN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIA FOR QUALITY. EARLY
LEARNING. SEQUEL IS A STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT SUPPORTING ELEVEN
THOUSAND CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
THAT AIMS TO RAISE PROGRAM
QUALITY. AND EXPAND HIGH
QUALITY CARE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA'S MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM. THE FINAL PRESENTER- OF
OUR OPENING PANEL BERMAN BLOBBY
MARIA ANTOINETTE HUNDREDS.
APPARENT WITH PARENT VOICES SAN
FRANCISCO MISS HUNDREDS BRINGS
UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE FROM HER
EXPERIENCE NAVIGATING.
CALIFORNIA'S SUBSIDIZED CHILD
CARE SYSTEM SHE HAS SERVED ON
THE CALIFORNIA PRESCHOOL
DEVELOPMENT GRANT. PARENT
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. WELCOME TO
YOU ALL THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND SHARING YOUR INSIGHTS
WITH US TODAY. AND WITH THAT MS
MORE PLEASE PROCEED DID WITH
YOUR TEST. GOOD MORNING. MY
NAME IS JULIE MORE I HAVE BEEN
A FAMILY CHILD WRITER. IN
MARINO VALLEY FOR OVER FIFTEEN
YEARS I RUN A TWENTY FOUR HOUR
DAYCARE AND I EMPLOY FOR
ASSISTANCE. I AM A MEMBER OF MY
DEALING. CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
UNITED. JOINT PROJECT S. C. ARE
YOU D. W. ABSOLUTELY I ALSO AM
A SINGLE MOTHER OF THREE GROWN
CHILDREN THAT NEED NEEDS TO.
WORKING WITH CHILDREN IS MY
PASSION. I LOVE WHAT I DO BUT
WHEN THE PANDEMIC FIRST. I WAS
VERY WORRIED I LIVE WITH AN
AUTOIMMUNE CONDITION THE FEAR
OF GETTING SICK IS STILL VERY
REAL. WORK THE GOVERNOR CALLED
ESSENTIAL WORKERS HE ASKED US
TO PROVIDERS TO STEP UP AND
CARE FOR THE CHILDREN OF OTHER
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. I STEP UP
CHILDREN I CARE FOR PARENTS YOU
WORK IN NURSING RETAIL AND
FORCE ME I KEEP WORKING SO THEY
KEEP WORKING. BUT JUST TELLING
US TO STOP. WASN'T ENOUGH WE
NEED A ROAD MAP TO MAKE THE
PANDEMIC ERA OF CHILDCARE WORK.
THE EARLY DAYS WERE EXPRESSLY
CHAOTIC THERE WAS SO MUCH
UNCERTAINTY. AND I WAS NERVOUS
THAT IF I DIDN'T DO EVERYTHING
JUST RIGHT OR GET EVRY FAMILY
TO AGREE TO PUT A MASK ON YOUR
CHILD. THAT COULD WOULD BE
CERTAIN TO ENTER MY DAYCARE.
AND THEN WE FOUND OUT THE
SCHOOLS WERE SHUTTING DOWN. NOW
ALL THE STUDY AND WORK
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHERS. I
HAVE A DISTANT LEARNER WITH
ADHD. WE HAVE TO KEEP HIM
ENGAGED ONLINE LEARNING
MEANWHILE THERE'S TODDLERS IN
THE OTHER ROOM SINGING SONGS
AND DOING SOMETHING THAT IS
MORE INTERESTING. MY GOSH HE
DOESN'T WANT TO SIT STILL AND
PAY ATTENTION TO WHAT AWKWARD
DON'T CALL. I SCRAMBLED TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WAS GOING TO
WORK I WAS TRYING TO HELP
FAMILIES. HEY KOBE SERIOUSLY
WITHOUT LIVING IN FEAR. MOST OF
ALL I WAS TRYING TO KEEP OUT
AND STAY OPEN. AS MUCH AS I
WANT TO I CAN NOT BE AROUND THE
STAFFING KIDS BECAUSE OF MY
HEALTH ISSUES. SO I HAD TO HAVE
I HAD TO HIRE NEW EMPLOYEES AND
CREATE TWO SEPARATE ROOMS TO
HELP THE KIDS SOCIAL WE
DISPENSE. I HAD TO TAKE
EVERYTHING OUT AND REMODELED TO
MEET PUBLIC HEALTH AND
LICENSING GUIDELINES. WHAT
SAVINGS I HAD WENT TO MAKE
THOSE CHANGES AND TO PURCHASE
WHATEVER PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
AND CLEANING SUPPLIES I CAN
FIND. OPERATE THE TRUCK YOU'RE
ON MY OWN WITH ALMOST TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS IN GRANTS
MY EXPENSES ARE ALREADY PRETTY
HIGH BECAUSE OF COLD IT I SPENT
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS EVERY
GRANT INSIGHT BEEN WENT TOWARDS
KOBE NINETEEN EXPENSES IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. I SPENT
ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
CABLE NOW IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. MY PAYROLL ALMOST
TRIPLED TO THIRTY ONE THOUSAND.
I WAS SHUT DOWN BY PUBLIC
HEALTH FOR HAVE YOU CALLED IN
MY DAYCARE TWICE WHAT'S SO MANY
OF US OPERATIN. WHAT ON RAZOR
THIN MARGINS IT'S NO WONDER WE
HAVE LOST OVER SIX THOUSAND
PROVIDERS DURING DISTRAUGHT
DEMI. I HAVE TO ADMIT THERE ARE
TIMES WHEN I THOUGHT ABOUT
GIVING UP. IN MY STAFF WOULD
REASSURE ME THEY'D SAY DON'T
WORRY MISTER LEE WE GOT THIS.
IT MAY TURN OUT TO BE RIGHT BUT
ONLY FOR THE MOMENT. SO MUCH OF
THE CHAOS UNCERTAINTY WE WENT
FOR A COULD HAVE BEEN AVOIDED
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCIES ARE
NOT COMPLETELY UNFORESEEN IF WE
TRULY CARE ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S
CHILD CARE SYSTEM. WE WOULD
HAVE A MUCH BETTER WE HAVE WE
WOULD HAVE BEEN MUCH BETTER
PREPARED. CHILD CARE IS THE
BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY. IT'S
THE WORK THAT MAKES ALL OTHER
WORK POSSIBLE. WE NEED TO
INVEST IN THE STATE'S CHILD
CARE SYSTEM DURING THE GOOD
TIMES SO THAT WE CAN WITHSTAND
THE HARD TIMES THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU IS MORE
ADMINISTRATION PLEASE. THANK
YOU CENTER NEWMAN AND THE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE FOR THIS
INVITATION. I'LL START BY
SAYING I DON'T LOOK ANYTHING
LIKE THE TYPICAL CHILD CARE
PROVIDER- THE AVERAGE CHILD
CARE PROVIDER IS A THIRTY SIX
YEAR OLD WOMAN- LIKELY WOMAN OF
COLOR- TODAY LET'S CALL HER
MARIA. REGARDING CHILD CARE
AFTER ATTENDING YOU SEE CLASSES
AT NIGHT. BECAUSE AFTER CARING
FOR HER KNEES SHE HAVE THIS
FEELING THAT WOULDN'T GO AWAY.
THE FEELING OF LOVE SEEM TO
CHANGE YOU CAN MAKE IN A
CHILD'S LIFE. THE FEELING THAT
THIS IS WHAT HER LIFE'S PURPOSE
IS. AFTER FIVE YEARS OF CLASSES
THREE YEARS OF TEACHING. TO
BANK LOANS AND MANY I'LL USE
FROM FAMILY AND FRIENDS. REOPEN
A ONE CLASS FROM CHILD CARE
CENTER SO SHE CAN MAKE CHANGE
IN MORE CHILDREN'S LIVES. BASS
FORD JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY SIX YEARS AFTER STARTING
HER CHILD CARE. SHE'S BEEN
RUNNING AND EXPANDING IT NOW
SHE HAS FOUR CLASSROOMS AND
SHE'S AS PASSIONATE AS EVER.
BUT SHE'S TIRED SHE'S TIRED OF
THE CONSTANT RATCHETING UP OF
REQUIREMENTS TIRED OF THE
ANNUAL THREAT OF PK TAKING AWAY
HER PROGRAM AND TIRED OF STILL
BEING TREATED LIKE SHE'S JUST A
BABY SITTER. THE END THAT
PANDEMIC HITS ANDREA IS
ENVELOPED WITH UNCERTAINTY AND
STRESS. BUT SHE ENTERS
CONTINUING TO SERVE FAMILIES
GROW NEARLY ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND PAYING HER TEACHERS
DIRECTLY OUT OF HER MEAGER
PERSONAL SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
THINGS ARE HARD HARDEST THEY'VE
EVER BEEN. BUT THINGS DON'T
WORK OUT SHE TELLS HERSELF.
FOUR MONTHS LATER JULY
FIFTEENTH. ZERO COVER CASES SO
FAR. WEARING MASK SOCIAL
DISTANCING KEEPING YOUR
TEACHERS IN THEIR OWN
CLASSROOMS. THE STATE RELEASED
AS A PDF A NEW COHORT INCLUDING
GUIDANCE. LIMITING THE SIZE OF
HER CLASSROOMS RESTRICTING
HORATIO'S REQUIRING HER TO
DIVIDE CLASSROOMS WITH FLOOR TO
CEILING NONPERISHABLE BARRIERS
AND KEEP HER TWO YEAR OLDS SIX
FEET APART AT ALL TIMES. SHE'S
RE READ IT TEN TIMES. THAT'S
WHAT IT SAYS SHE HAS TO DO THAT
STUFF. SHE CAN'T BELIEVE IT AND
SHE SIMPLY CAN'T DO IT. SHE
ALREADY CAMPAIGN RENT SHE CAN'T
MODIFIER PROGRAM TO THE
STANDARDS AND SHE CAN'T EVEN
KEEP HER TEACHERS EMPLOYED WHEN
THE THREAT OF COVERAGE IS SO
GREAT. NOW THESE THINGS ARE NOT
GOING TO WORK OUT. IT'S TIME TO
QUIT THROW IN THE TOWEL AND
SINCE NOONE WILL TAKE OVER
CHILDCARE DURING A PANDEMIC SHE
SUCH A DOWN FOREVER. REMOVING
ALL NINETY SIX TUCKER SPOTS.
BUT THE STORY IS NOT OVER C. A
WEEK AFTER CLOSING MARIA TALKS
TO A FRIEND AND HERE'S AT THE
COHORT INCLUDING PDF WASN'T
ABOUT REGULATIONS THAT AFTER
ALL. IT WAS SIMPLY PROVIDED AS
GUIDANCE. BUT THERE IS NOT A
LAWYER SHE CAN'T DIFFERENTIATE
SHOULD SHALL MUST. AND SHE
ALWAYS DOES RIGHT BY OUR
CHILDREN OUR FAMILIES OUR STAFF
IN THE STATE. WELL THIS
GUIDANCE WAS MEANT TO HELP
PROVIDERS NAVIGATE BUILDING
SAFETY PROCEDURES. BUT MANY OF
THEM OUT OF BUSINESS. BECAUSE
IT WASN'T CLEAR THAT IT WAS
JUST GUIDONS. MANY OF THEM
TURNED A SEQUEL AND NONPROFITS
LIKE OURS FOR HELP. AS THEY
COULD NOT GET CLEAR
COMMUNICATIONS FROM STATE
AGENCIES. THOSE WE HELPED AND
MANY STAYED OPEN. BUT MANY LIKE
MARIA DIDN'T GET HELP UNTIL
IT'S TOO LATE. IT'S NOT A REAL
PERSON. BUT RATHER
REPRESENTATION THE EXPERIENCES
OF HUNDREDS OF CHAU CARES. MANY
OF WHOM ARE STILL EXPERIENCING
THE SAME EXACT NEEDLESS ISSUE
TODAY. SINCE MARCH 202-200-0100
AND SIXTY CHAO CARES HAVE
PERMANENTLY CLOSED STATEWIDE.
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS MEANWHILE
AND DO WELL. BUT GETS STUCK IN
THE OPAQUENESS OF GOVERNMENT
SPEAK. THEY GET SNAGGED IN THE
RED TAPE RED TAPE OF LICENSING
PROCEDURES AND THEY GET
PUMMELED WITH LEGISLATION THAT
SHRINK THEIR RESOURCES AND
INCREASES THEIR EMOTIONAL DEBT
EVERY SINGLE YEAR. THE
LEGISLATORS AND AGENCIES. WE
ASK FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS TO
BE GIVING CLEAR AND CONSISTENT
GUIDANCE. WE ASKED FOR THE
ERASURE OF UNNECESSARY RULES
AND REGULATIONS THAT DO MORE
HARM THAN GOOD. WE ASK FOR THE
SAME RESPECT CARE INDECENCY. TO
BE GIVEN THE CENTRAL CHILD CARE
WORKERS. AS THEY GET TO OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES EVERY DAY.
AND ABOVE ALL YES LEGISLATORS
HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR PROVIDERS.
B. THE CHILD CARE LEGISLATOR-
BACKS WHO BACKS UP AND STANDS
UP FOR PROVIDERS WHO OTHERWISE
DON'T HAVE A VOICE. BUILD
BRIDGES INSTEAD OF BLOCKADES L.
DISCOURSE INSTEAD OF DISCORD.
AFTER ALL ADVOCATING FOR CHILD
CARE IS ADVOCATING FOR OUR
CHILDREN'S FUTURES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MITCH RICHMOND AND
MISSION HUNDREDS PLEASE. HI
GOOD EVENING SORRY GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY MANAGEMENT GROWING AT
JANICE AND I JUST WANNA START
STAYING THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE TO REPRESENT ALL THE WOMEN
MOTHERS AND IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
STRUGGLED TO WORK AND CARE FOR
THE NEEDS OF OUR CAN'T STAND UP
AND RUNNING. AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE AND THEN MAKE IT WAS
VERY CONFUSING. STRESSFUL
INSTRUCTING MY TUCKER PROVIDER
CLOSED. BECAUSE SHE WAS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE VIRUS. I
WAS WORKING FROM HOME AND
PROVIDING. SOME NAZARIAN LEGAL
SERVICE MY SON JUST TURNED FOUR.
EMISSIONS IS TROUBLES. HE WILL
CRY AND HE WILL ASK ME WHEN I'M
GOING BACK TO TUCKER INSTANTLY
IT WAS STARTING TO HAVE A VERY
DIFFERENT BEHAVIOR CHANGES. IT
WAS VERY ISOLATING AND I DIDN'T
KNOW HOW TO SUPPORT HIGH
SCHOOL. AND MANAGE MY WORK. I
THINK THE MYSTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVOR THE ISOLATION MINISTER
JEAN FULLER IT DIDN'T HELP MY
MENTAL HEALTH. AFTER SOME TIME
METALLICA PROVIDER RE OPEN BUT
ONLY FOR BY CATCH. IT WAS FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE. BY THE TIME I
SAW THE EMAIL IT WAS TOO LATE%
SHE FILL OUT HER SPACE WITH A
FIVE SPOT. I WAS DEVASTATED
AGAIN. THE NEW HOMELESS PROGRAM
OPENING SAN FRANCISCO AND I WAS
ABLE TO APPLY TO BECOME A
SHELTER MONITOR MAKING THE
INITIAL WORK. I WAS PROUD TO
CALL FROM. I'M TRYING TO MEET
WRITE WHERE. TO GET MY TAKAB.
BECAUSE THEY WERE WORKING FROM
HOME TO WEEKS WENT BY BEFORE
FOR I CAN GET A HOLD OF HIM.
WHEN A DEAD HE TOLD ME THAT I
EARN TOO MUCH TO QUALIFY. YOU
SEE MU THANK YOU WASN'T SURE
ABOUT THE PROGRAM AFTER THE
PROGRAM WORK. I DIDN'T THINK I
MAKE TOO MUCH RENTAL BUT I ALSO
DIDN'T HAVE THE ENERGY. TO
FIGHT FOR MY SHOULD SHOULD BE.
IT WAS SUCH AN OVERWHELMING.
SITUATION I NEEDED TO GIVE THE
SHELTER WILL DROP I WAS ABLE TO
FIND INNER CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WHO WORKED OUT A DEAL WITH ME I
PASS OUT OF POCKET FOR THREE
MONTHS. THOSE THREE MONTHS WERE
VERY STRESSFUL. ALL OF OUR
MONEY FROM FRIENDS. I WORK
OVERTIME. I DID EVERYTHING.
CHILD CARE. YOU CAN RECALLS.
CAN I SPOKE WITH SOMEONE AT
CAMPBELL'S REMINDING ME. THAT I
AM POWER. OKAY NEED TO FILE FOR
MY- I HAVE TO SPEAK TO MY CAR
SIMPLEMENTE SPECIALIST MY BOSS
TALK KIDS. MANY WEEKS. FINALLY
GET MY TOP TEN ABOUT YOU BACK
THANK FOR IT RIGHT NOW I AM
WORKING TO TIME SUNDAY GIVE-
RESTAURANT TO CHILDCARE MONDAY
TO. I HAVE AND FAMILY HELP ME.
ON SUNDAYS THE- RIGHT TACKLE
CLOSED. EVEN AS I WAS MY TO FOR
THESE. I THAT I COULD HELP FOR
THE SUNDAY. THIS IS A BIG
CHALLENGE FOR FAMILY. WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT WE DO BUT WE DON'T
KNOW. THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN CASE
WORKERS AND FAMILIES AND THE
PANDEMIC MADE IT MADE IT EVEN
WORSE. I'VE BEEN A TALK
ADVOCATE FOR ALMOST FIVE YEARS.
AND YET I STRUGGLE TO NAVIGATE
THE SYSTEM. I CAN IMAGINE ALL
THE PARENTS FALLING THROUGH THE
CRACKS. ALL THE MOMS TO SPEAK-ANOTHER LANGUAGE LIKE WILL-
FEEL SO ISOLATED FIGURE OUT
THESE GLOBAL PANDEMIC UNDER
OVER. IT'S SCARY. I WILL NEED
TO DO BETTER. ANOTHER ISSUE
FEDERAL WORRY ABOUT HIS FAMILY
FEAST. I AM WORKING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK MY NAME SO MANY
FAMILIES WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO
PAY THE FEES. THE FEES WERE
FROZEN FROM THE BEGINNING OF
THE PANDEMIC. BUT FOR SOME IS
FOR USE IN ANY PERSONAL CARE
LIKE ME. THEY'RE NOT FROZEN.
SINCE AUGUST. I CAN TELL YOU I
USE EVERY DOLLAR IN MY
PAYCHECK. I'M UTILITIES RENT
FOOD AND GAS. I KNOW WE HAVE
ALMOST ONE BILLION IN NEW
FEDERAL HEALTHCARE FUNDS.
PLEASE PLEASE THERE PLEASE HELP
MORRISONS WORKERS GET TODD CARE
ASSISTANT. MANY OF US ARE
SOCIAL WORKERS. AT WORK REALLY
REALLY HARD THEY ALSO NEED
FIFTEEN OR WARNING IT SHOULD BE
TEMPORARY. WHAT TIME IS IT IT'S
A STABLE ON INTERRUPTED CARE.
WE CAN WE CAN. WE CAN THAT WE
CAN DEPEND ON. WE SHOULDN'T BE
PLAYING FIELD FEES UNTIL WE ARE
IN A PLACE WHERE WE CAN AFFORD.
SO MANY OF US WORKS NICE
WEEKEND. THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
TALKING OPTIONS FOR MEDICARE.
WE SHOULD GIVE PROVIDERS MORE
FUNDING. FOR BEING FOR BEING
OPEN DURING NONTRADITIONAL
HOURS TOMORROW WHAT MOST OF
THEM WILL BE WILLING TO WORK
WITH FAMILIES LIKE MINE I'M
LOOKING. WHEN I FINISH PAYING
BACK I WILL CONTINUE TO FIGHT
FOR ALL THE MOTHERS ON THE WAY
LAST. I WANT TO DO FOR THEM TO
AND THEIR CHILDREN. WANT THREE
THREE SITUATION. BUT THEIR
STOCK OR PARENTS WHO WANT TO
TAKE A NEW JOB OR GO BACK TO
SCHOOL I CANNOT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
CHILD CARE. I AM WORRIED ABOUT
ALL THE KIDS MUSING ON THE
SOCIAL INTERACTIONS. HAVING
STRANGE QUALITY. CARE I WILL
ALLOWS THE KIDS TO BE KIDS. AND
HELP REPAIR A LOT OF THE HARM
OF THE CAN GET THAT THE
CONDEMNING HAS COST THANK YOU
SO MUCH. AND HAVE A WONDERFUL
DAY. THANK YOU MISSIONERS FOR
YOUR VERY MOVING TESTAMENT AND
THANK YOU TO THE OTHER TWO
PANELISTS AS WELL. AS PART OF
OUR EXAMINATION SHOCKER ISSUES
ARISING OUT OF THE PANDEMIC WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL. TITLED PRESERVING CHILD
CARE CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AS THE PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY PERSISTS WE'LL HEAR
FROM FOR PROVIDERS AND POLICY
EXPERTS ABOUT. EXCUSE ME ABOUT
THE PRESSURES THE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM IS STILL UNDER AS THE
ECONOMY STRUGGLES PARTICULARLY
FOR WORKING FAMILIES. AS
SCHOOLS RELY ON ONLINE DISTANCE
LEARNING AND WHILE UNCERTAINTY
CONTINUES TO PLAGUE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. THE FIRST SPEAKER ON
THIS PANEL WILL BE MISS JUDY
SINCE THE MORA FAMILY CHILD
CARE PROVIDER LEADER. AND A
MEMBER OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
UNITED MISTER MOORE HAS
EXPERIENCED FIRST HAND HOW
CRITICAL IT IS FOR PROVIDERS TO
BE PRESENT AND FULLY INVOLVED
AT EVERY POINT. IN THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESSES THAT SHAPE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
CALIFORNIA. WILL THEN HEAR FROM
GREG MERRICK THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF EXPLORE
CHILD CARE A PROVIDER
DELIVERING EMPLOYER SPONSORED
CHILD CARE TO THE EMPLOYEES AND
FAMILIES OF SPACEX. IN
HAWTHORNE CALIFORNIA. BETTER
PROVIDER WAS OPERATED
CONTINUOUSLY THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC MISTER MERRICK QUICKLY
LEARNED TO CONTINUALLY ADAPT
HIS PROGRAMS OPERATIONS IN
ORDER TO KEEP CHILDREN FAMILIES
EMPLOYEES SAFE. WHILE
RESPONDING TO RAPIDLY CHANGING
CONDITIONS OR THIRD PRESENTER
WILL BE ELSA JACOBSON THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY A
CHILD THREE SIXTY WHERE SHE
WORKS TO FURTHER POLICIES. THAT
ADVANCE EQUITY IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AT THE
LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS
AND TO ENSURE THE COMMUNITY
VOICES TRY POLICY. THE FINAL
SPEAKER AND PANEL NUMBER TWO
WILL BE DONE A SNEER INJURE
CHIEF STRATEGY OFFICER FOR THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER. AND
A CURRENT MEMBER OF THE FIRST
FIVE COMMISSION FOR SACRAMENTO
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR TESTIMONY MR
MAURA. WOULD YOU PLEASE START
THINGS OFF. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME. AND I AM A
TELCO PROVIDER IN VICTORVILLE.
AND I'VE BEEN A TALKER PROVIDER
FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS I AM ALSO
A MEMBER OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS UNITED. A JOINT
PROJECT OF THE ACLU AND YOU D.
W. A. F. S. C. M. T. A LOT GOES
ON IN OUR HOME FAMILY CHILD
CARES EVERY DAY I PROVIDING
NURTURING ENVIRONMENT AS WELL
AS AN ACADEMIC EDUCATION. TO
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN WILL BE
SUCCESSFUL IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. UNFORTUNATELY THE
CULTIC PANDEMIC HAS PUT A REAL
STRAIN ON CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
WE RISK EXPOSURE TO THE TO THIS
LIFE THREATENING VIRUS ON A
DAILY BASIS I PERSONALLY
PERSONALLY KNOW MANY PROVIDERS
WHO HAVE GOTTEN SICK AND
THANKFULLY SURVIVE. HOWEVER I
ALSO KNOW PROVIDERS WHO HAVE
PASSED AWAY AFTER BECOMING
INFECTED FROM THE CHILD WHO
CAME IN SICK. AND HEIR PARENTS
WERE NOT COMPLETELY HONEST WITH
THE PROVIDER. YES WE ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. WE KNOW OUR
WORK IS MORE NECESSARY THAN
EVER. WE ARE GIVING OUR
CHILDREN STABILITY ANY TINY BIT
OF NORMALCY IN THESE UNCERTAIN
TIMES. WE ARE KEEPING THEM
LEARNING AS SCHOOLS REMAIN
CLOSED. AND WE ARE HELPING
PARENTS WERE ALSO ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AS THEY CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
DURING THIS CRISIS. EVERY
MORNING WE TAKE IN OUR LITTLE
ONES AND EVERY DAY WE GO TO
EXTREME EFFORTS TO ENSURE THEIR
SAFETY AND OUR OWN. WE HAVE
ADDED EXTENSIVE CLEANING
MEASURES TO OUR PROGRAM. WE
CLEAN AND SANITIZE. WASH HANDS
CLEAN AND SANITIZE WASH HANDS
AGAIN ALL DAY. NEVER THE LESS
WITH A SMILE ON OUR FACE WE
TACKLE DISTANCE LEARNING I HAVE
FOR SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN A
KINDERGARTENER TO FIRST GRADERS
ANY THIRD GRADER. TO
ACCOMMODATE THEM FOR CLASS I'VE
HAD TO ADD ANOTHER SPACE TO OUR
CENTER. WE MADE A PLAY ROOM OUT
OF OUR- OUR GARAGE. VERY
NOTHING. SO WE MADE A PLAY ROOM
OUT OF OUR GARAGE- SO THAT WE
CAN KEEP OUR CHILDREN YOUNGER
CHILDREN FROM DISTRACTING OR
DISTANCE LEARNERS. WE ASSISTED
CHILDREN WITH NAVIGATING THE
INTERNET GOOGLE CLASSROOM CLASS
DOJO ZONE OR WHATEVER PROGRAM
THE TEACHER HAS CHOSEN FOR
THEIR CLASS FOR THEIR TWO TO
THREE HOURS OF SYNCHRONOUS
TIME. THE OTHER TWO TO THREE
HOURS OF ASYNCHRONOUS TRYING WE
ASSIST WITH VARIOUS AGE LEVELS
SIMONS. WE TEACH AND SUPPORT
THEM WITH THEIR BATH LESSONS WE
PROOFREADER WRITING ASSIGNMENTS
WE LISTEN TO THEM READ. WE HELP
THEM WITH THEIR END OF UNIT BIG
PROJECTS. THROUGH IT ALL WE
PREPARE MEALS AND YOUR BEST TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE A SAFER.
ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR CHILDREN.
BUT THE SYSTEM BROKEN. AS I'VE
HAD BECAUSE I'VE HAD TO DO ALL
OF THIS WITH LITTLE TO NO
RESOURCES FROM THE STATE
BECAUSE OF THIS EVEN THOUGH WE
ARE ESSENTIAL AND HAVE BEEN ON
THE FRONT LINES DURING THE
SPEND DOWN NEXT PROVIDERS ARE
STRUGGLING TO STAY OPEN. THERE
ARE MANY ADDED COST TO OPERATE
DURING THE PANDEMIC. I'VE HAD
TO RENT STORAGE SPACE TO PUT
AWAY EXCESS CHOICE SO THERE'S
MORE ROOM FOR JUST. NINETY I
HAD TO TAKE A LOAN TO COVER THE
COSTS FOR ADDITIONAL CLEANING
AND TO ENSURE I CAN DISINFECT
AT STAKE THE NATURAL PRODUCTS.
AND THERE'S ALWAYS A CONSTANT
WORRY OF EXPOSURE. AS MANY
PROVIDERS HAVE EXPERIENCED NOT
ALL PARENTS QUARANTINE THEIR
CHILDREN WHO HAVE COME IN CLOSE
CONTACT WITH COLD. AND WHEN
PROVIDERS HAVE TO SHUT DOWN TO
QUARANTINE MANY OF US DO NOT
GET PAID. BECAUSE PARENTS ARE
RESOURCE AND AGENCIES SWITCH
PROVIDERS WHEN THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE IN QUARANTINE.
LEADING TO RESOURCE AGENCIES
NOT PAYING THE PROVIDER WHO HAD
TO QUARANTINE. PARENTS ARE ALSO
BY PASSING THE NECESSARY
QUARANTINE AND POSSIBLY
EXPOSING OTHER CHILD CARE STE.
A LOT HAS BEEN ASKED TO TELL
CARE PROVIDERS AND WE HAVE
STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE. I URGE
YOU TO STAND WITH US AND HELP
STABILIZE CHILD CARE BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF PAID
COVERT NINETEEN CLOSER DAYS.
FOR PROVIDERS. WHEN WE HAVE TO
CLOSE THE CURRENT TEAM AND JUST
AS IMPORTANTLY GUARANTEEING
PAYMENTS FOR THE SHUTDOWNS.
PROVIDER PROVIDING GREATER
FINANCIAL SUPPORT YOUR CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS FOR THE
INCREASED COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THE FACILITATING DISTANCE
LEARNING AND SECURING PP AND
CLEANING SUPPLIES. DEVELOPING A
CLEAR PLAN TO WORK WITH COUNTY
SAM FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
TO ENSURE PRIORITY. CONTACT
TRACING BETWEEN HOME HEALTHCARE
AND CHILD CARE CENTERS IN
ADDITION TO SCHOOLS AND TESTING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. THE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC HOWEVER SINCE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY UNTOLD
NUMBERS OF CHILD CARE CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE PERMANENTLY
SHUT THEIR DOORS. OPERATING
UNDER CURRENT CONDITIONS IS
CHALLENGING FOR ALL BUT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR MANY SO OTHERS
WILL SURELY FOLLOW. SUPPORTING
PUBLIC HEALTH IS EVERYONE'S
COLLECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY AND
CHILD CARE CENTERS HAVE SHOWN
THAT THEY'RE DOING THEIR PART
SUCCESSFULLY. CALIFORNIA IS
FACING A CHILD CARE CAPACITY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE CRISIS.
WHICH HAS NOT EVEN BEEN FULLY
REALIZED IT'S NOT TOO LATE TO
ACT AND THERE STEPS THE STATE
CAN TAKE TO HELP CONTAIN THE
CRISIS. SO WHAT CAN CALIFORNIA
DO. I'M GOING TO FOCUS ON JUST
ONE THING THE ONE THING THAT
MAY VERY WELL HAVE THE GREATEST
POSITIVE IMPACT. THE ISSUE IS
COHORT SIZE. WE ALL AGREE THAT
MAINTAINING STABLE GROUPS THAT
ARE SMALL AS POSSIBLE IS
IMPORTANT TO REDUCE THE RISK OF
INFECTION AND LIMIT POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE. HOWEVER ACCORDING HAS
A CORRESPONDING. OF LIMITING
THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN A CHILD
CARE CENTER CAN AND ROLL
THEREBY CONSTRAINING ROBIN.
SINCE MOST CHILD CARE CENTERS
OPERATE UNDER THIN MARGINS
CAPPING ENROLLMENT MEANS
CENTERS CAN AT BEST BREAK EVEN.
MORE TYPICALLY THEY'RE
OPERATING AT A LOSS AND USING
PERSONAL RESOURCES TO COVER THE
DIFFERENCE. THIS CAN ONLY
CONTINUE FOR SO LONG BEFORE A
CHILD CARE CENTERS FORCED TO
CLOSE ITS DOORS. WITH
ENROLLMENT LIMITED AT
INDIVIDUAL CHILD CARE CENTERS
THAT MEANS CALIFORNIA'S OVERALL
CHILD CARE CAPACITY IS REDUCED.
AS WE HOPEFULLY EMERGE FROM
PANDEMIC EMERGENCY RESPONSE
MODE THIS YEAR IT'S CRITICAL TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
COAL COURT LIMITS ON CHILD CARE
CAPACITY. IT CHILD CARE CENTERS
MUST LIMIT ENROLLMENT WORTH
THEY NO LONGER OFFER IN ROOM
UNTIL BECAUSE THEY NO LONGER
EXIST. FAMILIES WILL HAVE A
HARD TIME GOING BACK TO WORK
WHICH WILL CONSEQUENTLY PUT A
DRAG ON CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
FOR A LONG TIME TO COME. ON THE
SUBJECT OF CO HOARDING THE LAST
pOF SOCIAL SERVICES IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. ISSUED GUIDANCE FOR
CHILD CARE PROGRAMS AND
PROVIDERS WAS ON JULY
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY.
WHILE THE GUIDANCE PROVIDED IN
JULY FOUR MONTHS AFTERTHE
START OF THE PANDEMIC MAY HAVE
BEEN APPROPRIATE AT THE TIME.
IT SHOULD BE NOTED THAT ITS
ORIGINAL INTENT WAS TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS TO FOLLOW WHEN STUDENTS
MEET FOR TARGETED SUPPORT AND
INTERVENTION SERVICES WHILE THE
SCHOOL IS CLOSED TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. FOR REASONS THAT
ARE NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR CHILD
CARE CENTERS WERE INCLUDED IN
THIS CATEGORY EVEN THOUGH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES STRICTLY REGULATES
CHILD CARE CENTERS AND
DETERMINES CHILD CARE CAPACITY
BASED ON THE SQUARE FOOTAGE OF
CLASSROOMS. INTERESTINGLY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES REQUIRES MINIMUM
INDOOR SQUARE FOOTAGE IN CHILD
CARE CENTERS AT THIRTY FIVE PER
CHILD. IF YOU DO THE MATH THE
MINIMUM SQUARE FOOTAGE REQUIRED
TO MAINTAIN SIX FOOT FOR
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IS A BIT LESS
THAN THIRTY PER INDIVIDUAL. THE
POINT IS THIS CHILD CARE
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ALREADY LICENSED TO ENSURE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING FOR UP TO
THE MAXIMUM NUMBER OF CHILDREN
THEY ARE ALLOWED TO ENROLL. BUT
CHILD CARE CENTERS ARE AT YET
ANOTHER DISADVANTAGE. UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S RE OPENING
FRAMEWORK FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS ONCE THE SCHOOL IS OPEN
THE COHORT SIZE IS UNSPECIFIED.
MEANING THE NUMBER OF GROUP
MEMBERS CAN VARY BASED ON THE
SIZE OF THE PHYSICAL SPACE
PROBE PROVIDED MEMBERSHIP IS
FIXED AND STABLE. THERE IS NO
SUCH CONSIDERATION FOR CHILD
CARE CENTERS WHICH POSES
SERIOUS SHORT TERM CONSEQUENCES
TO THE VIABILITY OF CHILD CARE
CENTERS THE SUCCESSFUL RE
OPENING OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND THE LONG TERM STATE OF
CHILD CARE CAPACITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO HERE'S THE KEY TAKEAWAY.
REGARDLESS OF THE RATIONALE FOR
PUTTING GREATER OPERATING
RESTRICTIONS ON CHILD CARE
CENTERS THAT ARE IN PLACE FOR
K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS.
CONTINUING WITH THIS APPROACH
WILL HAVE DEVASTATING LONG TERM
CONSEQUENCES THE CHILD CARE
CAPACITY AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
TITLE TWENTY TWO REGULATIONS
ARE MORE THAN ADEQUATE TO
ENSURE COHORT SIZES ARE KEPT AS
SMALL AS POSSIBLE AND PROVIDES
CHILD CARE CENTERS WITH THE
SAME IMPORTANT FLEXIBILITY THAT
K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS HAVE
TO OPERATE SAFELY. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE ON
THIS PANEL I APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU'RE DOING TO HELP THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND WISH
YOU ELL AS WE PREPARE TO
EMERGE FROM THIS CRISIS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER MERRICK
MISS JACOBSON PLEASE YOUR
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO FILL THIS BEAR WITH ME FOR
ONE MINUTE I'M GOING TO SHARE
MY SCREEN SO THAT YOU CAN SEE
MY POWER POINT. ALL RIGHT
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN SEE THAT. I'M
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ALSO
JACOBSON AND I SERVICE THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY FOR
CHILD THREE SIXTY OR A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
PROVIDES COACHING ASSESSMENTS
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING TO NEARLY SIX HUNDRED
EARLY LEARNING PROVIDERS ACROSS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO
WORK VERY HARD TO ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITY VOIGTS STRIVES POLICY
BY ELEVATING THE PERSPECTIVES
OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
PARENTS LEGISLATORS LIKE
YOURSELVES. LAST FALL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA AND THE CHILD CARE
LINES OF LOS ANGELES WE
ADMINISTERED AN ONLINE SURVEY
TO NEARLY SIX HUNDRED CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND TEACHERS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY WE LEARNED A
GREAT DEAL ABOUT THEIR CLOSELY
RELATED CHALLENGES AND I LIKE
TO SHARE SOME OF THE KEY
FINDINGS WITH YOU. IN PART TO
SHOW THAT THE EXPERIENCES THAT
HAVE BEEN SHARED TODAY BY
PROVIDERS AND PARENTS ARE
EMBLEMATIC OF CHALLENGES THAT
ARE WIDESPREAD. TO PROVIDE SOME
CONTEXT ABOUT THE SURVEY. 74%
OF SURVEY RESPONDENTS WORKED AT
LICENSED CHILD CARE CENTERS AND
26% WORKED AT LICENSEDFAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES. WHERE CARE IS
PROVIDED IN AN INDIVIDUAL'S
HOME. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
PROVIDER RESPONDENTS RECEIVE
SOME FORM OF STATE AND OR
FEDERAL FUNDING. AND A LITTLE
OVER HALF PROVIDE EITHER
EXCLUSIVELY IN PERSON CARE OR
DISTANCE LEARNING AND FORTY
THREE POINT 2% ACCOMPLISH THE
HERCULEAN FEAT. A PROVIDING
BOTH IN PERSON CARE AND
DISTANCE LEARNING. IN ADDITION
A LITTLE OVER 85% OF SURVEY
RESPONDENTS WERE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THIS IS UNSURPRISING
GIVEN THAT WOMEN OF COLOR MAKE
UP THE MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHILD CARE WORKFORCE AND THEY
HAVE DEEPLY FELT THE IMPACTS OF
THE KOBE NINETEEN CAN DAMAGE.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT THE CHALLENGES
THEIR PROGRAMS WERE FACING LOW
ENROLLMENT WAS THE MOST
FREQUENTLY CITED CHALLENGE. OF
THE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
PROVIDERS TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER THEY
WERE OPERATING AT OR BELOW
CAPACITY SEVENTY ONE POINT 6%
REPORTED THAT THEY WERE
OPERATING BELOW CAPACITY. AND
64% OF THESE PROVIDERS WERE
CENTERS. AS YOU CAN IMAGINE
LOWER ENROLLMENT HAS MEANT LESS
INCOME FOR PROVIDERS WHO
OPERATED ON RAZOR THIN MARGINS
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. OF
THE THREE HUNDRED A PROVIDERS
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE REVENUE FIFTY POINT 6%
REPORTED THAT THERE WAS A GAP
BETWEEN THEIR MONTHLY COSTS AND
THEIR REVENUE OR REIMBURSEMENT.
IT'S WORRISOME BUT PERHAPS
UNSURPRISING THAT MANY
PROVIDERS HAVE CLOSED
TEMPORARILY OR PERMANENTLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. ADDING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES BETWEEN MARCH AND
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY THEY
WERE NEARLY SEVEN THOUSAND
CLOSURES OF LICENSED FAMILY
CHILD CARE HOMES 200-040-0403
OF WHICH WERE PERMANENT. AND
WE'RE OVER NINETY FIVE HUNDRED
CLOSURES OF LICENSED CHILD CARE
CENTERS FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN OF WHICH WERE PERMANENT.
THESE NUMBERS DO NOT INCLUDE
ANY TEMPORARY AND PERMANENT
CLOSURES OF THE APPROXIMATELY
NINETEEN THOUSAND LICENSE EXAM
PROVIDERS THAT RECEIVE STATE
SUBSIDIES. SOME PROVIDERS
INITIALLY HAD TO CLOSE
TEMPORARILY TO PREPARE THEIR
SITES TO MEET NEW HEALTH AND
SAFETY PROTOCOLS AND OTHERS AS
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY HAVE HAD TO
CLOSE AND THEN REOPEN SOMETIMES
MULTIPLE TIMES WHEN THEY'RE
BEEN CUT OUTBREAKS. AND SEVERAL
THOUSAND OTHERS HAVE CLOSED
THEIR DOORS FOR GOOD. IN OUR
SURVEY WE ALSO ASKED PROVIDERS
WHAT COSTS THEY WERE MOST
WORRIED ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
COVER DURING THE YEAR. AND THE
CUSTOMERS JUST MOST WORRISOME
AMONG BOTH CENTERS AND FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WERE
CLEANING SUPPLIES IN PP.
FACILITIES COSTS AND PERSONNEL.
BEING ABLE TO AFFORD RENT AND
MORTGAGE CLASS WAS ALSO CITED
BY FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
AS A TOP CHALLENGE. NOW WE KNOW
THAT MANY PROVIDERS RECEIVE
CLEANING SUPPLIES IN PP FROM
THEIR LOCAL RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL AGENCIES. THIS IS
CERTAINLY BEEN HELPFUL TO
PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED
SUCCESSFUL COORDINATION BETWEEN
MULTIPLE AGENCIES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. BUT AS YOU HEARD FROM
PROVIDERS TODAY THE MOST
CONSISTENTLY AND DAILY CLEAN
AND DISINFECT COMMON SURFACES
IN TOYS CONDUCT TEMPERATURE
CHECKS AND WEARING CHANGE MASKS
SO THEY NEED FOR P. P. AND
CLEANING SUPPLIES IS ONGOING.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THEIR
FACILITIES COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH MEETING NEW HEALTH AND
SAFETY REQUIREMENTS. IN OUR
SURVEY PROVIDERS MOST
FREQUENTLY INDICATED THAT THEY
WOULD UTILIZE ANY FACILITIES
IMPROVEMENT DOLLARS TO BETTER
SUPPORT HAND WASHING SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACILITIES
MODIFICATIONS. FOR EXAMPLE THIS
FUNDING MIGHT BE USED FOR
PORTABLE SINKS NO TOUCH FAUCETS
OR SOAP AND PAPER TOWEL
DISPENSERS TO HELP WITH HAND
WASHING. OR IT MIGHT BE USED
FOR PARTITIONS OR CONVERSIONS
OF SPACES IN THE CLASSROOMS IN
ORDER TO MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCING. OR THE FUNDING
MIGHT BE USED TO MAKE
MODIFICATIONS TO ENSURE GREATER
OUTDOOR SHADE AND WEATHER
PROTECTION TO ENABLE CHILDREN
TO SPEND MORE TIME OUTDOORS. IN
OUR SURVEY WE ALSO ASKED
TEACHERS AND PROVIDERS WHAT
TYPE OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THEY WERE MOST
INTERESTED IN RECEIVING. AN
INTERESTINGLY THE TRAINING
TOPIC MOST FREQUENTLY REQUESTED
WAS WORKING WITH CHILDREN WITH
CHALLENGING BEHAVIORS. WE KNOW
THAT FOR MANY OF OUR CHILDREN
THEIR BEHAVIOR IS DIRECTLY
RELATED TO TRAUMA THAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED BEFORE THEY ENTER
THE CHILD CARE SETTING WHICH
HAS ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED BY
COULD. EASY PROFESSIONALS HAVE
EXPRESSED DESIRE TO BE EQUIPPED
WITH STRATEGIES ON HOW TO
BETTER SERVE THESE CHILDREN IN
THEIR CARE. EVERY DAY EARLY
CHILDHOOD PROVIDERS AND
TEACHERS PROVIDE A CRITICAL
MEASURE OF SECURITY AND
STABILITY TO THOUSANDS OF
PARENTS MANY OF WHOM ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. A TAKE ON
THE DIFFICULT TASK OF HELPING
VERY YOUNG CHILDREN STAY
SOCIALLY DISTANCING MAST OR
CREATING ENGAGING DISTANCE
LEARNING ACTIVITIES FOR THREE
AND FOUR YEAR OLDS. AND THEY
PUT THEIR OWN HEALTH AND THE
HEALTH OF THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
AT RISK ON A DAILY BASIS. IS
RESILIENT COMMENDED EASY
PROFESSIONALS THE MAJORITY OF
WHOM ARE WOMEN OF COLOR.
DESERVE THE STATE'S RECOGNITION
AND SUPPORT THREE FLEXIBLE
STIPENDS TO COVER CLEANING
FACILITIES AND OTHER CODE
RELATED COSTS FOR RE OPENING
GRANTS FOR EXTENDING THE HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION. THROUGH
TARGETED PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND THROUGH FAIR
PAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MISTAKEN
NEXT HEAR FROM DONNA'S INJURE-
MISS OR PER GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TODAY ABOUT
THE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THE
CHILD CARE SYSTEM IS PROVIDED
TO OUR STATE DURING THE
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF THE OTHER
PANELISTS- WHO REALLY HAVE
SHOWN A LIGHT ON. ALL OF THE
HARD WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE BY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND WE ARE
ALL INDEBTED TO THEM FOR THE
RISKS THEY TAKE AND THE AND THE
ROAD WORK THAT THEY HAVE DONE.
AS OF. AS OR MY OR- THE CHILD
RESOURCE CENTER IN A NON
ORGANIZATION WE SEARCH SERVE A
LARGE- SERVICE AREA IN LOS
ANGELES AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY. AND WE OUR SISTER
AGENCY TO SIMILAR ORGANIZATIONS
ALL AROUND CALIFORNIA AND I
WANT TO TALK TO DO A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE LESSONS WE'VE LEARNED.
WHAT IS NEEDED AND WHAT HAS
BEEN WORKING AND WHAT WE NEED
TO DO GOING FORWARD TO HELP OUR
CHILD CARE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
OUR PROVIDERS RECOVER. SO I
THINK THE LESSON THAT THE WORLD
LEARNS OUR COMMUNITIES LEARNED
WAS ONE THAT WE ALREADY KNEW
CHILD CARE IS ESSENTIAL. AND IT
IS ESSENTIAL FOR OUR FAMILIES
TO BE ABLE TO GO TO WORK AND IT
WAS APPARENT IN THE VERY EARLY
HOURS OF THE PANDEMIC THAT THAT
ONE IS CRITICAL FOR OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. WHAT WE ALSO
LEARNED AS MANY OF OUR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE NOT VERY
HIGHLY PAID AND MANY OF THEM
ARE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE A CHILD
CARE SUBSIDY BUT THERE AREN'T
ENOUGH SUBSIDIES TO GO AROUND
BECAUSE OUR SYSTEM ONLY SERVES
ONE IN NINE ELIGIBLE CHILDREN-
WE ALSO LEARNED THAT. OUR LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS IN PLACE BUT
NOT WELL RESOURCE AND IT WORKED
VERY QUICKLY TO RESPOND TO THE
PANDEMIC AND I WILL TALK ABOUT
SOME OF WHAT WAS DONE. BUT
THERE'S MORE TO DO AND THE
CRITICAL NEED TO HAVE THAT
LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE
TO SUPPORT PROVIDERS. AND
SUPPORT THE FAMILIES IS IT IS
NECESSARY FOR US TO GET THROUGH
THE REST OF THE PANDEMIC AND
ALSO AS WE MOVE FORWARD. SO OUR
LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE REALLY
RESPONDED VERY QUICKLY TO THE
PANDEMIC- ARE PROGRAMS WHICH
ARE LARGELY HOUSED IN COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS OR- LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES WORKED
QUICKLY WITH OUR LOCAL FIRST
FIVE COMMISSIONS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. TO TRY TO GET
RESOURCES OUT TO PROVIDERS.
WE'VE WORKED THROUGH OUR STATE
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ESSENTIAL
WORKER VOUCHERS FOR THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA MY AGENCY ALONE IN
THE WORLD TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED ADDITIONAL FAMILY IS.
TO RECEIVE CHILD CARE SERVICES
AND WE ALSO WORKED TO PROVIDE
REFERRALS TO HELP THEM FIND
CHILD CARE AS MANY PROVIDERS
WERE CLOSED AS HAS BEEN ALREADY
STATED. OUR RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL PROGRAM WORKS WITH
FIRST FIVE AND OTHER LOCAL
ENTITIES TO PROVIDE NECESSARY
SUPPLIES AND SERVICES- AT MY
AGENCY WE'VE DISTRIBUTED OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND FACE
MASKS FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND DIAPERS THIRTEEN
THOUSAND BAGS OF FOOD AND
TWELVE THOUSAND DIFFERENT TYPES
OF CLEANING SUPPLIES. AND IT'S
SOMETHING WE CONTINUE TO DO ON
A REGULAR BASIS PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC WE WEREN'T A
DISTRIBUTION CENTER WE WEREN'T
USED TO RECEIVING PALLETS OF
GOODS THAT WE THEM DISTRIBUTED
TO OUR PROVIDERS BUT WE ARE NOW
AND IT IS SOMETHING WE CONTINUE
TO DO ON A WEEKLY BASIS AT ALL
OF OUR LOCATIONS. WE'VE ALSO
RECEIVED A LOT OF LOCAL
DONATIONS FROM BUSINESS AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO HELP
BUT THERE STILL IS NOT ENOUGH
AND WE CONTINUE TO TRY TO SEEK
RESOURCES AND SUPPORT FOR OUR
PROVIDERS. WE ALSO WORK THROUGH
GRANTS THAT WERE PROVIDED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ISSUE STIPENDS TO CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THIS PAST FALL- IT
WAS  START- WE NEED TO DO MORE
AND IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT I
THINK THAT PROVIDERS COMMENTS
ABOUT. THE COSTS THEY HAVE
TAKEN ON TO BE OPEN AND
OPERATING AS WELL AS THE
LIMITED ADULT TO CHILD RATIOS
MAKE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO STAY IN BUSINESS AND IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE. TO SUPPORT THOSE
EFFORTS. WHAT I REALLY LIKE TO.
ON IS HAS WERE. AND WE NEED TO
DO GOING FORWARD THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC- THE FIRST THING IS
THE IMMEDIATE ACCESS TO
VOUCHERS FOR ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
AS I MENTIONED WE'VE ENROLLED
THOUSANDS OF ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THERE ARE THOUSANDS MORE
WAITING WE STILL ARE WORKING TO
TRY TO MAKE SURE FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED. THE OTHER THING TO HAVE
IN CONSIDERATION AS WE LOOK AT
THIS IS THE COST OF HAVING
SCHOOLS CLOSED ON THE CHILD
CARE SYSTEM. MANY OF THE
PROVIDERS MENTIONED THAT THEY
ARE NOW. KRACHT DURING K.
TWELVE EDUCATION IN THEIR CHILD
CARE SETTING AND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS IT'S ADDITIONAL COST
IT'S ADDITIONAL INTERNET IT'S
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TIME AND
STAFFING BUT IT'S AN ALSO AN
ADDITIONAL COST TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE PAYING FOR FULL TIME
CARE FOR SCHOOL AGED CHILDREN.
AND WE HAD- AN INCIDENT IN THE
FALL WHERE WE HAD TO GO BACK
AND TRY TO INCREASE THE DOLLARS
WE HAD AVAILABLE UNFORTUNATELY
IT IS SUCCESSFULLY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THE
LEGISLATURE BECAUSE IT COSTS
MORE TO HAVE THE SCHOOLS CLOSED
IN THE CHILD CARE SYSTEM. WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
CASH SUPPORT TO PROVIDERS. WE
ARE LOOKING AT ALL THE
DIFFERENT COST PROVIDERS ARE
HAVING TO ENCOURAGE THAT'S
CRITICAL FOR THAT. AND WE ALSO
NEED TO CONTINUE PAYING
PROVIDERS BASED ON THEIR
ENROLLMENT NOT THE ATTENDANCE
WE KNOW FAMILIES ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO MITIGATE
THEIR OWN RISK AND TO KEEP OUR
PROVIDERS STABLE AND OPEN WE'VE
GOT TO PAY THEM. TO KEEP THEIR
DOORS OPEN. AND WE ALSO NEED TO
DO SOME WORK YOU HEARD THAT
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
PROVIDERS THAT ARE TEMPORARILY
CLOSED WE'VE LOST SOME THAT
WILL NEVER COME BACK BUT WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS TO KEEP OUR
PROVIDERS OPEN. TO HELP
STABILIZE THEM AND TO RE OPEN
SOME OF THESE PROVIDERS. WHO
ARE TEMPORARILY CLOSED. THAT'S
TO GET US THROUGH THIS PANDA.
ONCE WE START TO STABILIZE
THERE ARE ONGOING THINGS THE
STATE NEEDS TO CONSIDER TO
REALLY RESTORE AND BRING OUR
PROVIDERS BACK SO THAT OUR-
PARENTS HAVE THESE OPTIONS SO
THEY CAN GO TO WORK FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE HAVE TO INCREASE
OUR REIMBURSEMENT RATES TO
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS. WE'VE
ASKED THESE WOMEN LARGELY WOMEN
OF COLOR TO STEP UP TAKE RISKS
THEY BEEN HEROES DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND WE'RE NOT PAYING
THEM THE CURRENT MARKET COST OF
PROVIDING CARE I THINK THAT
SHAMEFUL AND I THINK WE NEED TO
DEAL WITH THAT IMMEDIATELY WE
NEED TO PROVIDE ON GOING
SUPPORT TO OPEN A NEW PROVIDERS
AND SUPPORT THOSE THAT ARE IN
BUSINESS TO EXPAND THEIR
SERVICES. WE'VE LOST QUITE A
CHUNK OF OUR CHILD CARE SUPPLY
WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH BEFORE WE
STARTED SO THIS IS GOING TO BE
A REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE WE
NEED TO MAKE SOME INVESTMENTS
IN THIS LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT HAS BEEN WORKING SO HARD
TO SUPPORT FAMILIES AND
PROVIDERS I AM I WILL SAY THE
RESOURCE AND REFERRAL PROGRAMS
HAVE HAD THE SAME. FUNDING FOR
THE BOUT THE PAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AND OBVIOUSLY THAT HASN'T
KEPT UP WITH THE COST OF DOING
WHAT WE'RE ASKED TO DO I'M SO
THERE ARE NEEDS FOR THAT LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE
STRENGTHENED SO WE'RE READY FOR
FUTURE- CHALLENGES THAT OUR
STATE WILL FACE AND LAST BUT
NOT LEAST I WANT TO REALLY
UNDERSCORE WHAT ELSE MENTIONED
ABOUT TRAUMA. WE ARE ALL
EXPERIENCING A TRAUMATIC EVENT
THIS YEAR HAS BEEN TRAUMATIC
FOR EVERYONE ESPECIALLY FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND FOR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS WE NEED TO THINK
ABOUT ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORTS FOR OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS FOR OUR FAMILIES AND
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR YOUNG
CHILDREN OFTEN YOUNG KIDS ARE
NOT. CONSIDERED HARD TO OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH RESPONSE SYSTEM
THEY DO DISPLAY THEIR TRAUMA
THROUGH CHALLENGING BEHAVIOR
AND IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WERE THERE WITH
OUR PROVIDERS AND PARENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS. AROUND
THAT NEED. TO RECOVER AND BE
RESILIENT AND MOVE FORWARD IN
THEIR LIVES IN A HEALTHY WAY.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THE TIME TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK YOU TO EACH OF THE
PANELISTS AS WELL. LET'S MOVE
TO THE FINAL PANEL- WILL UNDER
THE HEADING OF CHILD CARE IN
THE POST PANDEMIC ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WE WILL HEAR FROM
EXPERTS IN SOME OF THE ISSUES
AND PRIORITIES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S POLICYMAKERS
SHOULD CONSIDER AS WE SEEK TO
STABILIZE AND REINVIGORATE THE
SHELTER INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE
STATE IN ORDER TO BETTER
HARNESS THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS
THAT ACCOMPANY A ROBUST
EFFECTIVE TRUCKERS SYSTEM THAT
SUPPORTS FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS
OUR FIRST PANELIST WILL BE
DAVID RATTRAY THE PRESENT CEO
OF UNITE LA A NONPROFIT THAT
LEADS EDUCATION REFORM AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
INITIATIVES DESIGNED TO BENEFIT
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. WILL NEXT HEAR FROM
SHELLEY MEASURE CALIFORNIA
STATE DIRECTOR AT THE COUNCIL
FOR A STRONGER AMERICA A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION THAT
UNITES EADERS IN BUSINESS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE RETIRED
MILITARY TO ADVOCATE FOR
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES THAT
ENABLE KIDS TO BE HEALTHY AND
SUCCESSFUL OUR LAST PANELISTS
THIS MORNING WILL BE DR NANCY
HERBERT CHAIR AN EMERITUS
PROFESSOR IN THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD STUDIES DEPARTMENT AT
CAL POLY POMONA AND KOHLI
CONSULTANT THE PARTNERSHIPS AND
EDUCATION ARTICULATION AND
COLLABORATION IN HIGHER
EDUCATION ALSO KNOWN BY ITS
VERY CUTE ACRONYM PEACH. PEACH
CHANGE TO STRENGTHEN AND
SUPPORT PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT PATHWAYS AND
RELATED EDUCATION PROGRAMS FOR
BOTH THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
WORKFORCE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THANK YOU ALL FOR SHARING YOUR
INSIGHTS WITH THE COMMITTEE
THIS MORNING WE WELCOME YOU AND
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR TESTIMONY
MR RATTRAY IF YOU COULD PLEASE
REFER SEE. THANK YOU AND- THIS
MY VIDEO OF MY AUDIO WORKING
OKAY A PRETTY HERE'S ALL RIGHT.
IT IS YOU'RE GOOD. YEAH ALL
RIGHT OUT THAT AS A YES- WELL
FOR OF ALL THE SAN- THANK SO
MUCH FOR DOING THIS I BEEN VERY
MOVED. BYE BYE COLLEAGUES IN
I'M HOW TO- BE AMONGST THE REST
OF MY- IN HEARING THEIR-
INCREDIBLE TESTIMONY SO- I I'LL
BRING A PERSPECTIVE AS A FORMER
BUSINESS EXECUTIVE- I SPENT
TWENTY YEARS IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR IN SOME TRAINED TO THINK
MORE LIKE HOW TO BUILD A
BUSINESS. THEN I AM CERTAINLY
AN EXPERT IN EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION- AND SO ONE OF THINGS
THAT I WANTED TO SHARE AS WE
HAD JUST RECENTLY COMMISSIONED.
A STUDY TO LOOK AT THE BENEFITS
TO THE OVERALL ECONOMY. WELL
PAID- EARLY CARE AND WORKFORCE.
AND WE COMMISSION BEACON
ECONOMICS TO LOOK AT THIS IN L.
A. COUNTY- AND NOT
SURPRISINGLY- WHAT WE SHOWED
WAS. IN L. A. COUNTY WE PAID
OUR- REALLY CARE. IN IT WORKERS
LIKE WE SHOULD ASK. IT WOULD
ADD FIVE POINT TWO BILLION TO
EIGHT POINT ONE BILLION OF
ADDITIONAL ECONOMIC OUTPUT IN
THE LA ECONOMY ALONE. YOU CAN
IMAGINE SENATOR WHAT THAT WOULD
MEAN ACROSS THE WHOLE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S OF OUR
ATTEMPTED ON WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW IS THE BENEFITS TO
CHILDREN OF HIGH QUALITY AND
AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO CHILD CARE
AND- EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION-
SO. I WANT TO SHOULD I WILL
APPLY FOR THIS- AND- YOU STILL
HEAR ME OKAY. I WANT TO- TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT REBUILDING
THIS SECTOR- THE GOOD NEWS IS
IN STE DESPITE THE SEARCH
CHALLENGES THAT SPENT WELL
ARTICULATED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS POISED TO PROVIDE
ANOTHER FORTY BILLION. THROUGH
THE ONE POINT NINE TRILLION
DOLLAR. RESCUE ACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS PUTTING THROUGH
THE CONGRESS IN ON TOP OF THAT
DECEMBER MONEY WHICH IS ABOUT
TEN BILLION- WE EXPECT TO SEE
AS MUCH AS FIFTY BILLION. OF
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
DOLLARS THAT WILL BE WILL COME
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
CALIFORNIA WILL GET THE LARGEST
SHARE- OUR RECOMMENDATION IS
THAT THIS MONEY TO USE AND
REALLY INNOVATIVE WICKS. AND
WAYS THAT ARE NOT LIKE TYPICAL.
MOST OFTEN MONIES LIKE THIS IS
OUR PUT OUT ON A FORMULA BASIS.
AND BASED ON A ROMANCE AND WE
THINK A BIG PART OF IT SHOULD
BE USED MORE WITH MORE THE WAY
WE WOULD DO IF WE ARE VENTURE
CAPITALIST AND WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO STIMULATE. NEW
BUSINESSES COMING INTO
EXISTENCE AND IN THAT WAY I
THINK IT'S GONNA BE COUNTER TO
THAT FOR THE GOVERNMENT IT'S
HARD SOMETIMES FOR US TO THINK
THAT WAY AS THE PUBLIC SECTOR.
BUT I THINK WE ARE SUSPEND A
LOT OF THE NORMAL- KIND
REQUIREMENTS SUSPEND THINGS
LIKE- EVERY ALL MONEY GOES OUT
THE SON OF ROMANCE AND OTHER
SORT OF FORMULAIC THINGS. AND
MAKE LIKE A LOT OF OUR PREVIOUS
MY PREVIOUS COLLEAGUE SAID MAKE
A LOT OF THIS MONEY AVAILABLE
TO HELP THESE BUSINESSES
RECOVER AND RESTART. AND THAT
MEANS THIS NEED TO BE FLEXIBLE
DOLLARS MUCH LIKE THE PPP LOANS
WERE THAT WERE PUT OUT BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- THAT
PROVIDE CASH RIGHT UP FRONT AND
PROVIDE. RESOURCES TO HELP.
THESE CHILD CARE CENTERS IT HAD.
SHUT DOWN HARPER. WITH SOME C.
MONEY TO REALLY COME BACK. AND
GIVE THE- A GOOD OF TIME SO
THERE IS. CAN REALLY. REBUILD
ITSELF. AND WE NEED TO HAVE
SOME INNOVATION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE SOME OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FOLKS TO IMAGINE A DIFFERENT
WAY OF FUNCTIONING IN INCENTIVE
DOLLARS. AS MENTIONED EARLIER
ABOUT- CENTERS BEING OUT TO
OPEN STAY OPEN. TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN IN PROVIDE OUR PARENTS
WHAT THEY NEED- WE NEED A LOT
MORE CREATIVITY TO DO THAT. AND
THEN I WOULD JUST ADD THAT WE
NEED AN EYE TOWARD THE FUTURE
TOO WE SHOULD BE. USING THESE
RESOURCES TO REBUILD THE SECTOR
BUT MUCH LIKE- THE MASTER PLAN
THAT THE GOVERNOR EXPLAINED IN
COLORS PUT OUT- IN DECEMBER HE
HAS MAINTAINED A VISION TOWARD
TWENTY THIRTY AND HOW DO WE
BUILD THE SECTOR. THAT WE WANT
TO SEE. IN THE FUTURE SO THAT
IF WE DO THINGS IN THE SHORT
TERM WE'RE NOT ONLY BUILDING
BACK TO SECTOR BUT WE'RE ALSO
BUILDING AND IN A WAY THAT PUTS
US ON A TRAJECTORY TOWARD. THE
LONG TERM- KIND OF SECTOR WE
WANT TO SEE- SO THAT WOULD BE
MY BIGGEST ENCOURAGE MINISTERS
TO BE SUPER INNOVATIVE WITH THE
POINT THAT THE DOLLARS WERE
GOING TO GET- SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IT'S AN HONOR TO BE ON
THIS PANEL AND I'M I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS OR SUPPORT
IN THE FUTURE IN AB IDEAS THAT
FLOW FROM THIS. THANK AND THANK
YOU MISTER RECORD- NEXT TO MISS
MAJOR IF. YOU IF YOU WOULD
PROCEED PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORE. THE GIRL I CENTER
NEWMAN OF THE I YOU FOR
INVITING READY NAY HOME RECORD
TO TODAY HEARING I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SYSTEM SPECIFICALLY
IN RELATION TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC WELL BEING AS- MISTER
ACT REGISTERED BEFORE ME SO AS
A REMINDER MY NAME IS SHOWING
IS- I'M THE CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR
FOR THE COUNCIL FOR STRONG
AMERICA. THE UMBRELLA NONPROFIT
THAT INCLUDES READING NATION
WHICH IS A BUSINESS LEADER
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION WITH
OVER THREE THOUSAND EXECUTIVES
WHO WORKED ABOUT THIS SKILLED
WORKFORCE BY PROVIDING EVIDENCE
BASED SOLUTIONS WILL PREPARE
CHILDREN TO SUCCEED IN
EDUCATION WORK AND LIFE. SOME
BEHALF OF OUR CALIFORNIA READY
NATION MEMBERS. ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED HERE I WHO REPRESENTED
A FIRST SET OF SECTORS AND
SIZES OF COMPANIES I. WOULD
LIKE TO JUST TALK ABOUT TWO
POINTS. FIRST IS THE NOTION
THAT A ROGUE SAYS EARLY
LEARNING CARE AND ALL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR STATE
PLAYS A VITAL ROLE IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF THAT COMMUNITY.
WE HEARD ABOUT LA BUT THAT'S
TRUE ACROSS THE STATE WITHOUT
AFFORDABLE ACCESSIBLE AND
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING CARE NOT
ONLY DO WORKING FAMILIES AND
EMPLOYERS SUFFER BUT
SUBSTANTIAL AND LONG LASTING
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES OCCUR.
HOW HIGH ARE THE STAKES FOR OUR
WORKING FAMILIES TAX PAYERS AND
EMPLOYERS. ARE READY NATION
REPORT WANT TO STRENGTHEN THE
ECONOMY FIX THE CHILD CARE
CRISIS NOTES OF THE PROJECTED
ANNUAL COST OF LACK OF RELIABLE
INFANT TODDLER CARE IN
CALIFORNIA. IS NINE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS. THIS IS PRETTY
COLD AT NINE POINT ONE MILLION
AND THE FIGURE CONSISTS OF THE
LAST EARNINGS PRODUCTIVITY AND
REVENUE. I'LL JUST BREAK IT
DOWN AS THE ECONOMIC. OCCURS IN
AN INTER RELATED WAY. SO EACH
YEAR A CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF
THREE WITHOUT SUFFICIENT
CHILDCARE. FOR THOSE FAMILIES
THEY LIVE WITH AN AVERAGE OF
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS PER WORKING PARENTS.
AND LOST EARNINGS AND THEN TIME
SPENT LOOKING FOR WORK IT WILL
BE FLEXIBLE. IN OUR STUDY
PARENTS REPORTED REPORTED
SPENDING LESS TIME AT WORK DUE
TO CHILD CARE PROBLEMS ON
AVERAGE TWO HOURS PER WEEK.
THERE I WAIT THEY LEAVE EARLY
THEY MISSED DAYS ARE BEING
DISTRACTED I KNOW CERTAINLY
THAT HAPPENED FOR MYSELF WHEN
MY KIDS WERE IN CHILD CARE. AND
WE KNOW THAT WHEN. THAT HAPPENS
WE LOSE INCOME. ROSS ELEVEN
MILLION PARENTS CHILDREN UNDER
THE AGE OF THREE IN THE UNITED.
THE BURDEN IS SEVEN BILLION PER
YEAR. PANDEMIC HAS CERTAINLY
ONLY EXACERBATED EXISTING
CHALLENGES WHICH WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT HER PRIOR TESTIMONY AND
WE KNOW BECAUSE WE READ ABOUT
IN THE PAPER EVERY DAY. BUT
MOTHERS ARE CARRYING THE BURDEN
OF OUR INADEQUATE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM. AB BUCKMASTER IS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CHAMBER SAN MATEO COUNTY AND A
READING NATION MEMBER SHE'S A
LONGTIME ADVOCATE FOR CHILD
CARE POINTS TO STUDIES THAT
SHOW THE MAGNITUDE OF JOB
LOSSES FOR WOMEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. WILL HAVE A LONG TERM
IMPACT ON BUSINESSES ABILITY TO
HIRE AND RETAIN THE BEST
TALENT. AND AS WE HAVE HEARD
FROM OUR CHILD CARE HEROES. THE
COLEMAN NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
FORCED MANY MOTHERS OF THE
WORKS. OUT OF THE WORKFORCE.
TIME AWAY AND DECREASED
PRODUCTIVITY AT WORK DUE TO
CHILDCARE ISSUES. I DON'T MIND
THE CURRENT AND FUTURE ECONOMIC
STABILITY OF FAMILIES. IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT TO NOTE AS WE
HEARD FROM EARLIER HOME BASED
CHILDCARE AND ALL OF ITS FORMS
AS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
SUPPORTING MANY WORKING
FAMILIES. PARTICULARLY THOSE
THAT WORK IN NONTRADITIONAL
WORK SCHEDULES. IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE THESE PROVIDERS
CONTRIBUTE ONE POINT. FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS TO OUR ECONOMY.
BUSINESS EMPLOYED WORKING.
ISN'T OF A HEADER FIFTY TO. PER
WORKING. A REDUCED. AN EXTRA
HIGH BECAUSE- ANNUALLY ACROSS
THE THAT THIRTEEN BILLION PER
YEAR. IT JUST MAKES SENSE THAT
A WORKFORCE THE FLASK
PRODUCTIVE OR HAVE JUST A
SHORTER TIME. TENURE DO I CAN
AFFECT WORKING I DOWN MORALE
DIMINISHING PRODUCT QUALITY AND
POSSIBLY LOSING CLIENTS.
ADDITIONAL A. R. TAXPAYERS LOSE
AN AVERAGE OF SIX HUNDRED AND
THIRTY DOLLARS PER WORKING
PARENT AND LOWER INCOME TAX AND
SALES TAX REVENUE. AN AGGREGATE
THIS MONTH TO SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS NATIONALLY. THE SECOND
IS EXTENDING EARLY QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING CARE TO ALL
YOUNG CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
POVERTY IS AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO
DEVELOP A SKILLED AND DIVERSE
FUTURE WORKFORCE. WHEN WE DON'T
INVEST ADEQUATELY IN EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE OUR ECONOMY
TAKES A HIT IN FUTURE LOSSES
AND COSTS THAT WE OCCUR WITH
THAT WE ENCOURAGE SORRY ONE
WORKERS ARE NOT WELL TRAINED.
THEY HAVE TOO LITTLE OR THEY
HAVE TOO LITTLE EXPERIENCE AS
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD WE MUST BE CONCERNED
ABOUT DEVELOPING A SKILLED AND
COMPETITIVE WORKFORCE HAS
EXECUTIVE FUNCTIONING SKILLS TO
CONTINUE INNOVATING AND LEADING
ALL OF OUR WORKFORCE SECTORS
FORWARD. AS WE ALL HAVE HEARD
THERE'S A SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS
THAT BRAIN DEVELOPMENT FROM
BIRTH TO AGE FIVE SETS THE
FOUNDATION FOR A CHILD'S FUTURE
SUCCESS. SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
SKILLS IMPULSE CONTROL DECISION
MAKING AND MANY OTHER LIFELONG
SKILLS BEGIN EARLY. AND
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT HIGH
QUALITY EARLY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS DO YOU HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT WAS IN THE MOST
IMPORTANT. UNDER RESOURCE
CHILDREN. LATER IN LIFE THESE
SKILLS THAT I JUST MENTIONED
DEVELOPING CRITICAL THINKING
TEAM PLAYING AND OTHER
WORKFORCE COMPETENCY SKILLS.
THAT'S WHY HIGH QUALITY CHILD
CARE PROGRAMS ARE SO IMPORTANT.
WHETHER IT'S ON THE DEMAND SIDE
OR THE SUPPLY SIDE HAVING
ACCESSIBLE AFFORDABLE AND
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
IT IS TRULY VITAL PART OF OUR
LOCAL AND STATE ECONOMIES
NOTHING HAS MADE THAT CLEAR
THAN THIS PANDEMIC. LASTLYTHE
STABILITY THAT RELIABLE AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CHILD CARE
BRINGS ALLOWS FOR ECONOMIC
MOBILITY FOR MANY ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND LOW INCOME WORKING
FAMILIES WE HEARD A TESTIMONY
ABOUT THAT EARLIER. CALIFORNIA
IS HOME TO CLOSE TO TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF FOUR THIS REPRESENTS 13%
OF OUR NATION'S YOUNG CHILDREN
FOR THE FUTURE ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND GROWTH OF OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY. IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US TO ACTUALLY
INVEST IN A ROBUST AFFORDABLE
CHILD CARE SYSTEM AND IMPLEMENT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS PUT FORTH
BY MY COLLEAGUES BEFORE ME.
THANK YOU FOR A CHANCE TO
TESTIFY AND TO BE PART OF THIS
HEARING TODAY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IS MEASURED AND
NEXT UP- DOCTOR HER BUT- I WILL
THANK YOU MUCH FOR- INVITING ME
TO GIVE FROM A AT THIS HEARING-
I'M OF. PROFESSOR CHAIR THE
EARLY STUDIES TECH POLY POMONA.
ANAMOSA COACH OF HE WHICH A
HIGHER ED BECAUSE TO THAT CAN
OF. THE PHARMACIST SIX STATE IN.
TO USE TECH. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
HI. AND HERE I'M I. SIX I'M
FOLLOWING UP MANY OF THE THAT I
ALREADY. AND- THE PRE. SPEAKERS
TO WHAT IS TIME IMAGE SO. WELL
IF NOT PER OF BRAIN STRUCTURE
TO GO IN THE FOR FIVE YEARS
JAMES HOW HACKMAN HAS CREATED
IF HAVE A WALL EARLY TO
EXPERIENCE. YOUR ARE THE
ACHIEVEMENT CARE ACT GREATLY.
THE NEED FOR CHECK IS FOR TO
THE CRIME RATE BECAUSE DOWN FOR
THOSE CHILDREN WHO HAVE A CAR
EARLY EXPERIENCE THEY ARE
LIKELY HAVE A LIFESTYLE.
MENIKAH POINT OF VIEW EVERYONE
DOLLAR YOU PUT IN YOUR WAY HOW
TO GET A SEVENTY TWO CHRIS
ANNUAL RETURN FOR MONEY SO THE
M. AS WELL WHERE IT I ACTUALLY
HERE IS THAT- TO HAVE A CALL.
EARLY CHILD X. WE NEED CALL A
WERE. AND A QUALIFIED WORKFORCE
IS A KEY TO BOTH OUR HUMAN AND
IT KIND RECOVERY FROM THE-
ESTATE POINTED OUT OF THEM PLAN
WILL- RELEASED EARLY CHILDHOOD
IN THIS CENTER. AND WE'RE WITH
THE MASS PLAN AND ONE OF THEM
WAS WORKFORCE. WHAT I WANT
ARGUES IS ORDER TO HAVE A CALL
TO WORK FOR. WE NEED. FIRST OF.
FOR TO. UNDER CHILD DEVELOPMENT
WE NEED TO UNDER DUAL LANGUAGE.
SPECIAL AND HAS BEEN MATCH HERE
IS MUCH. TRAUMA AND CARE. AND-
WITH WITH I WOULD ALSO TO OUR
THAT YOU CAN'T BE A CALL OF
WORK UNLESS YOU PAY A CALLER.
PRACTICALLY MAKES. AND THAT FOR
MANY CENTER. A DEGREE- POSSIBLY
A NEW CHILDHOOD. FONG KA AROUND
WOULD BE A VERY. GOOD WAY TO
SUPPORT- TO. WE ALSO NEED
CONTAIN. IN THE- HI MATT
PROGRAM. THAT IS A PRO THAT
SUPPORTS STUDENTS. NAVIGATING
HIGHER END WE ALSO TO ORDER A
SCHOOL WITH WOULD HAVE SCHOOLS.
THE BURIED PLACE TO GET IT.
PRIOR WE NEED TO UP WITH
FORGETTABLE INSTEAD SCORELESS.
TO GET A BE A- BELIEVE WE GET
VERY LITTLE. PAIN BUT- A LOAN
THE LOAN SO GET TO GO BE A IS
NOT. WE ALSO TO COME WITH
FUNDING THAT WAS STUDENTS FOR
THEY HAVE TAKE A OFF FOR SO
WEEKS OFF- A WEEK TO DO THIS.
PRACTICE AND AS THE- THE A
MASTER CITY WE NEED TO COME UP
A STACK UP. THAT'S THE WAY IT
SOME OF THE WAYS TO GET A
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE WE HAVE
ANOTHER ISSUE ONCE WE GET THIS
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE THEY DON'T
STAY WHY DON'T THEY SAY IT'S
NOT BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE EARLY CHILDHOOD WORKERS IN
FACT. OUR NEW PROGRAM WHICH
STARTED AT CAL POLY IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN IS THE FASTEST
GROWING PROGRAMMING CAL POLY
AND WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
GRADUATION RATE. SO WE CAN
PREPARE PEOPLE THE PROBLEM IS
THEY GET TO BE A- THEY MAKE
LIKE A DOLLAR MORE AN HOUR WITH
THE VA THAN A NON VA THEY GET A
MASTERS THEY GET NO REYES. THEY
GO OUT TRY TO WORK IN THE FIELD
IT'S NOT SUSTAINABLE SO THEY
COME BACK THEY GET A CREDENTIAL
THEN THEY GO WORK FOR THE K.
TWELVE SYSTEM IT'S A WIN FOR
THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM WE CANNOT
KEEP A SUSTAINABLE WORK FOR US.
IF WE DON'T COME UP WITH A
EIGHT A LIVABLE WAGE IT'S A
MATTER OF FACT IF YOU ARE A
PRESCHOOL TEACHER YOU ARE SIX
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE IN
POVERTY THAN IF YOU ARE IN THE
K. TWELVE SYSTEM. AND IF YOU
ARE A PRESCHOOL TEACHER COLOR
YOU'RE 50% MORE LIKELY THAN A
PRESCHOOL TEACHER A WHITE
PRESCHOOL TEACHER TO BE ON
HOLIDAY. SO THE POINT I'M
TRYING TO MAKE HERE IS ONE WE
NEED A QUALIFIED WORKFORCE THIS
WORKFORCE NEEDS TO BE WELL
TRAINED IN DEVELOPMENT. AND THE
SKILLS AND THE KNOWLEDGE TO
OFFER QUALITY OUR EARLY
CHILDHOOD WE NEED A SUSTAINABLE
WAGE AND WE WILL NOT KEEP THAT
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE WE ARE NOT
A PATHWAY FOR NEW PROFESSION WE
ARE HALFWAY. FOR A CREW DAY
GOVERNMENT IN EARLY CHILDHOOD I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO STATE THAT
IF WE COULD COME UP WITH- WELL
SUSTAIN QUALITY EARLY CHILDHOOD
WE WILL BOTH INCREASE. OUR
ECONOMIC CAN OUR HUMAN CAPITAL
AND THEN FINALLY I WANT TO
THANK YOU AND SAY NGUYEN HIGHER
ED ARE. VERY WILLING AND EAGER
TO WORK ON A- PLANS MAKE THE
WORK THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
YOU DR THERE YOU TO ALL OF THE
PAN COOPER. AS FAR- AT THIS
POINT RECEIVED NOW MOVE TO
QUESTIONS INCOME FROM OF THE-
BUT BEFORE WE DO I'D LIKE TO
INVITE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO WISH TO PARTICIPATE TO
PLEASE CALL IN NOW PLEASE DIAL
THIS TOLL FREE NUMBER.
844-291-6364 THAT'S EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE
SIX FOUR WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE
USE THE FOLLOWING ACCESS CODE.
526-400-3526 FOUR ZERO ZERO
THREE AND YOU'LL BE ASSIGNED A
PLACE IN THE QUEUE. AND NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
JERRY GONZALEZ. YES THANK YOU
AND MISTER CHAIR AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT PUTTING TOGETHER THIS
WONDERFUL PANEL I CAN ACUMEN-
IN THE MIDDLE SO MY APOLOGIES
BUT- THANK YOU TO ALL THE
PANELISTS AS WELL- YOU ALL HAVE
BEEN DOING A LOT OF GREAT WORK
IN IN THIS SPACE BUT MY
QUESTION I THINK IS SORT OF A
LARGER QUESTION AS TO WHAT
COULD BE DONE TO WORK- WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY- I KNOW A
LOT OF OUR BUSINESSES OBVIOUSLY
THEY WANT TO GET BACK. UP AND
RUNNING- AND THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT THEIR WORK
FORCE BUT ARE THERE ANY SORT OF
CREATIVE PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE
BEING DONE OR- THINGS TO KIND
OF LOOK AT- ON THE HORIZON.
WITH OUR BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
THAT'S RIGHT I THINK THAT WOULD
BE PROUD TO START A GOOD
QUESTION FROM THIS MEASURE. AND
MAYBE THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
THANKS THAT'S INTERESTING I
ACTUALLY THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION I ACTUALLY HAD A-
REQUEST FOR- COLLEAGUES TO TALK
ABOUT THIS EXACT ISSUE THERE
THERE IS A STUDYING THIS BEING
COMMISSION ON CREATIVE WAYS
BUSINESSES ARE INTERESTING- DAY
AT CHILD CARE CRISIS- SO I AM
HAPPY TO DO SOME FOLLOW UP WITH
ALL OF YOUR OFFICES AND SHARED
THAT CONTACT INFORMATION. ON
THE STUDY WILL BE PARTNERING
WITH THEM I'LL JUST GIVE YOU
ONE EXAMPLE OUR AND OUR ONE OF
OUR READY NATION MEMBERS HIS
CHIEF OF STAFF AT AM JANET
COMPANY IN THE BAY AREA. HAS
THEN- HAD BEEN THINKING ABOUT
THIS BEFORE THAT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC HAS REALLY SEEN THEM
MASSIVE IMPACT THEY'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT HOW HOW DIDTHEY
FIND SPACE TO PUT OUR AN ONSITE
CHILDCARE CERTAINLY A LOT OF
THE TECH COMPANIES IN THE BAY
AREA HAVE ONSITE CHILDCARE AND
MAKE THAT AVAILABLE FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES- BUT THEN ALSO-
BECAUSE AMGEN HAS HAD SUCH A
HARD TIME FINDING LAND IN THE
BAY AREA AS YOU KNOW IT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE- IS ALSO THINKING
ABOUT- HOW DO THEY PARTNER WITH
AN EXISTING PROVIDER TO. OFFER
SPACE FOR- FOR THEIR FOR THEIR
EMPLOYEES AND THEN LASTLY I
KNOW THAT MANY OF US HAVE HEARD
ABOUT BUSINESSES THAT PARTNER
WITH SPECIFIC TYPES OF
PROVIDERS WHO CAN PROVIDE
SPECIALTY CARE FOR KIDS WHEN
THERE IS AN ILLNESS- OR OTHER
SORT OF CHILD CARE EMERGENCY
THERE HAVE BEEN BUSINESSES
THAT- THAT DO THAT KIND OF
WORK. AND AS THEIR AS THEIR
JOBS SO THAT JUST A FEW- A FEW
WAYS AND AS I SAID I WILL
FOLLOW UP AND MAKE SURE THAT
YOU ARE ALL CONNECTED AND GET
THE INFORMATION AS THIS STUDY
INVOLVES. THANK YOU FOR THAT
I'VE OBTAINED MISDIRECTION I'M.
GUESSING YOU MAY HAVE SOME
COMMENTS AS WELL. SHE THANK YOU
FOR. THE QUESTION THINK YOU
MEMBERS FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
PAGE LEAVE- OBVIOUSLY RELATES.
TO THIS IS THE SAME ALL TOPIC
AS WE NEED TO SUPPORT. OUR OUR
NEW PARENTS- AND- THIS IS A
TIME WHEN SUPPORTING OR NEW
PARENTS THEN IT'S EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE IT ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THE NEEDS FOR TAKING
CARE OF INTENSE FROM ZERO TO
SIX MONTHS OLD IF OUR IF OUR A
NEW PARENTS GET TO STAY AND GET
COMPENSATED FOR THAT TIME- SO I
JUST RESET YOUR LEADERSHIP
ONE'S GOING FORWARD. I THINK
THAT OBVIOUSLY IS ONE THING
IT'S RELATED TO THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES WE NEED TO BUSINESS
COMMITTEE TO EMBRACE AND
SUPPORT NEW PARENTS. AND KNOW
ABOUT THE- CERTAIN THE
INCREASING POLICIES WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA FOR A LONGER PERIOD
AND FOR PROTECTED LEAVE FOR
SMALLER EMPLOYERS. TO YOUR
LARGER QUESTION I THINK THERE'S
TWO THINGS A BUSINESS CAN YOU
COME TO MIND IF THEY COME TO MY
FOR ME THAT THEY CAN DO ONE IS
JUST. THIS KIND OF WORK WE'RE
DOING WITH TODAY'S HEARING IS
BUILDING AWARENESS OF THE
BUSINESS TREATY OF WHY THEY
NEED TO SUPPORT PUBLIC
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION. SO THAT YOU'RE
ACCOMPLISHING WE NEED TO KEEP
DOING THAT EVEN BOLDER AND
BETTER ALL OF US. AND THAT'S
WHY WE ISSUED OUR BEACON
ECONOMICS REPORT TO TRY TO USE
BUSINESS SPEAK FOR AN
ECONOMISTS SAY YOU HAVE EVEN
MORE STAKE IN THIS THAN YOU
REALIZE. THE SECOND THING IS
THE BUSINESS COMMITTEE S. IS
GOOD AT REBUILDING BUSINESSES
THAT IS THEIR EXPERTISE THAT'S
THEIR GREATEST EXPERTISE. WE
SHOULD ENGAGE MORE OF THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY I USE OVER
DC EVENTUALLY CAPITALIST. AS
BEING MENTORS IN SUPPORT- SOME
OF OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
THAT ARE REALLY GOOD AT TAKING
CARE OF OUR CHILDREN BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE TRAINING IN HOW TO
OPERATE A BUSINESS IN SOME
CASES MANY DO BY THE WAY BUT-
AND SO I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
MORE ROBUST SORT OF INVESTMENT
AND- IN BUILDING UP THE KIND OF
REST OF FOUR OF BUSINESS
LEADERS. THAT CAN PROVIDE
MENTORING AND SUPPORT TO OUR
CHILD CARE. SECTOR ON HOW TO
READ BUILDING- THAT'S WHAT REST
ARE GOING TO BE TO DO NOW. IN
WE REALLY SHOULD THINK ABOUT IT
LIKE WE ARE SO CONCERNED WITH
OUR RESTAURANTS AND TRAVEL AND
TOURISM. AND THAT IS HOW DO WE
HELP THESE BUSINESSES REBUILD
THEMSELVES. I APPRECIATE THAT
ARE THERE ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS. OF PANELISTS WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK THIS QUESTION IT
IS A GOOD QUESTION- AND IF YOU
WOULD MY MISTER MERRICK. I
THINK YOU LIVE IN THAT SPACE
SO- IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO THIS
JUST A LITTLE BIT. YES MY NAME
JUST BY WAY OF BACKGROUND- MY
COMPANY PARTNERS WITH EMPLOYERS
TO DEVELOP ON SITE- PRESCHOOLS
FOR THE BENEFIT OF- EMPLOYEES
CHILDREN- AND- TO THE OTHER
SPEAKERS POINT. YOU KNOW THAT
IS A BENEFIT THAT. ONLY A
RELATIVELY SMALL NUMBER OF
EMPLOYERS CAN PROVIDE- GIVEN
THE RESOURCES REQUIRED SPACE
CONSTRAINTS THINGS ABOUT THAT
NATURE- BUT I THINK THAT ARE
SORT OF KIND OF MELD. THE TWO
PREVIOUS COMMENTATORS POINTS I
THINK ONE OF WONDER.
PARTICULARLY INTERESTING WAY
THAT CHILD CARE CENTERS CAN
REBUILD THEIR BUSINESS SAYS IS
BY PARTNERING WITH EMPLOYERS
LIKE AMGEN WHO IS LOOKING FOR A
BENEFIT FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES BUT
BECAUSE OF SPACE CONSTRAINTS
CAN'T. DO THAT RIGHT AWAY BUT
TO THE EXTENT THAT EXISTING
CHILD CARE OPERATORS HAVE-
ADDITIONAL UNUSED CAPACITY YOU
CAN BASICALLY CREATE A CLEARING
HOUSE ALSO THAT THESE-
BUSINESSES. CAN HELP THEIR
EMPLOYEES MEET THEIR CHILD CARE
NEEDS AND ALSO GIVE ALL A STEP
A LEG UP THE CHILD CARE
OPERATORS WHO WANT TO FILL
THEIR CLASSROOMS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- ANY OTHER PANEL
SHOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO US
SENATE INTELLIGENCE QUESTION I.
I'D LIKE TO ADD JUST A COUPLE
OF THINGS I'M EIGHT I
APPRECIATE THAT THE ENGAGEMENT
OF THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND I
THINK ONE OF THE- BIGGEST
LESSONS OF THE PANDEMIC IS HOW
CRITICAL CHILD IS THE CHILD
CARE IS TO OUR ECONOMY. AND I
THINK HOW WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION WITH THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AS AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT CHILD CARE
IS AS IMPORTANT TO GETTING YOUR
EMPLOYEES TO WORK AS ROADS- IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND MAKING
SURE THEY'RE AT THE TABLE AND I
WANT TO ECHO. DAVID RAT RACE
COME COMMENTS ABOUT
UNDERSTANDING THE NEED FOR
PUBLIC INVESTMENT I THINK THERE
ARE COMPANIES THAT ARE IN A
POSITION TO DO SOME SUPPORT FOR
THEIR OWN EMPLOYEES BUT LARGELY
WE NEED A BROADER. ROBUST
SYSTEM THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF
OUR TWENTY FOUR SEVEN ICONOMI
AND HAS OPTIONS FOR FAMILIES
WHO WORK IN ALL TYPES OF
INDUSTRIES AND CAN BE FLEXIBLE
AND RESPONSIVE TO THEIR WORK
SCHEDULES AND PROVIDE A QUALITY
CARING. ENVIRONMENT FOR THEIR
YOUNG KIDS. THANK YOU. I MEAN I
COULD JUMP ADEQUATE COMMENT I'M
JUST TO PIGGY BACK ON WHAT
DONNA AND SOME OF THE OTHER
PANELISTS WERE MENTIONING I
THINK ANOTHER WAY FOR THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY TO GET
ENGAGED DESPITE WEIGHING IN ON
THE POLICY DISCUSSION AND WE'VE
CERTAINLY SEEN THAT WITH SOME
OF OUR BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS
IN LOS ANGELES WITH VALLEY
INDUSTRY AND COMMERCE
ASSOCIATION WITH THE L. A.
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND I
REMEMBER WELL SITUATION LAST
YEAR WHEN- THERE WAS A PROPOSAL
ON THE TABLE TO ADD TO LOWER
THE ALREADY LOW REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
SO WE HEARD THAT. THERE WAS AN
INTEREST FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN HEARING FROM
UNTRADITIONAL PARTNERS ON THIS
TOPIC NOT FROM THE USUAL
SUSPECTS AND SO THEY WERE
NUMBER BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS
WHO STEPPED UP- BIKE IT WAS ONE
OF THEM I THINK CANCEL FOR A
STRONG AMERICA- WITH THEIR
BUSINESS MEMBERS WAS ONE AND
MADE THE CASE THAT
REIMBURSEMENT RATE SHOULD
SHOULD NOT BE LOWERED AND THAT
MADE AN IMPACT SO I THINK- YOU
KNOW IN THE PUBLIC SPHERE
PARTICULARLY IN IN MATTERS OF
LEGISLATION IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS WHEN BUSINESS LEADERS
CAN STEP UP. ALONGSIDE
CHILDCARE. PROVIDERS- IT'S VERY
POWERFUL. WELL SIR AND ANY
OTHER PALACE I MOVE ON. THANK
YOU SO SENATOR LAMAR HAS A CO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR- AND I APPRECIATE ALL THE
COMMENTS THEY THINK IS THE ONE
WHO'S BEEN WORKING ON SOME
CHILD CARE ISSUES FOR YOU KNOW
A FEW YEARS WE'VE ALWAYS KNOWN
WE NEVER HAD ENOUGH SPOT WHEN
IT WAS SUBSIDIZE OUR
UNSUBSIDIZED. SO THE PANDEMIC
HAS JUST- MEET THIS CHALLENGE
SIGNIFICANTLY GREATER- FOR OUR
STATE AND- I KNOW THERE'S A FEW
LESS THAT ARE WORKING ON
LEGISLATION TRYING TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS. BUT IT
STILL CREATES THIS ISSUE AND-
WE YOU KNOW WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH CERTAINLY THE GUIDELINES
AROUND PANDEMICS. I HAVE BEEN
VERY CAUTIOUS AND WE'VE HEARD A
LOT FROM CHILD CARE PROVIDERS-
WHETHER IT'S CENTERS OR HOME
CARE THAT- YOU KNOW THEY'VE HAD
TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF SPOTS
BECAUSE OF THE GUIDELINES AT.
AND IS THE MATH ISN'T WORKING
OUT THE WITH THE WAY THAT- IT
WOULD NEED TO IN ORDER TO KEEP
SOME OF THESE FACILITIES ALIVE
AND SO- I HEARD A FEW
SUGGESTIONS THAT WERE MADE IN
TERMS OF POLICY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN FACE COULD.
ADDRESS WHICH OF COURSE
INCLUDES RATE REFORM BETWEEN
WE'VE BEEN OUT FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS I KNOW CENTER LABELS-
CONTINUES TO LEAD THAT THAT
CONVERSATION- BUT YOU KNOW AT
THE IN LIGHT OF. THE FACT THAT
CHILD CARE COULD LOOK DIFFERENT
AND WE HAD A CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE MEANING. OF THE PARTNERING
THE BUSINESS WHAT OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS THAT
COULD THE LEGISLATURE THINK OF
IN TERMS OF REMATCH ANNIE WHAT
CHILD CARE LOOKS LIKE- IN IN
CERTAINLY THAT- IT IS SOMETHING
THAT. THE LEGISLATURE I THINK
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN. THANK
YOU IT WOULD ANY PANELIST TO
RESPOND. SURE I HATE THIS IS
THOMAS NARINDER WITH CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER I THANK YOU
SENATOR LIMóN FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY OVER THE YEARS AND I
KNOW YOU KNOW CHILD CARE ISSUES
IN A DIFFERENT WAY NOW THAN YOU
DID A COUPLE YEARS AGO. WE ARE
I'M ACTIVELY WORKING ON THE
EFFORTS RELATED TO
REIMBURSEMENT RATE REFORM WHICH
IS REALLY FOUNDATIONAL TO BEING
ABLE TO SUSTAIN AND BRING NEW
PEOPLE INTO THE WORK FORCE- SO
IWOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
PUT THAT FIRST AND FOREMOST ON
OUR LIST I THINK OTHER THINGS
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT IS.
MAKING THE CHILD CARE SYSTEM
MORE FLEXIBLE FOR FAMILIES
MAKING IT MORE ACCESSIBLE BY
REFORMING AND RE RETHINKING THE
NEED FOR FAMILY FEES- EXPANDING
ACCESS TO NONTRADITIONAL TYPES
OF PROVIDERS UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE ARE HOURS OF THE DAY AND
DAYS OF THE WEEK THAT AREN'T.
REALLY PROVIDED IN A
TRADITIONAL BRICK AND MORTAR
FACILITY AND I THINK
OPPORTUNITIES TO REALLY BUILD
OUR WORK FORCE I WE'VE BEEN
WORKING LOCALLY ON
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TRYING
TO BRING PEOPLE INTO THE FIELD
AND ONE OF THE BIGGEST BARRIERS
IS HOW MUCH WE PAY. ON THERE
IT'S NOT THAT PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED IT'S THAT WE HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO PAY A COMPETITIVE
WAGE TO BRING NEW PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE- IS SOME OF THAT- COULD
IT COULD BE- PARTNERED WITH
BUSINESS I KNOW WE'RE DOING A
LOT OF WORK PARTNERING WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. AND LOOKING
AT HOW TO STRENGTHEN OUR
WORKFORCE AND BRING PEOPLE TO
THE TABLE IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND LASTLY I'D I
THINK THAT CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT OUR MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM
SO THAT PARENTS HAVE TRUE
CHOICE FOR THEIR CHILDREN BIRTH
THROUGH SCHOOL AGE. IN PROGRAMS
THAT MEET THEIR NEEDS- AND I
KNOW WE TALK A LOT ABOUT LITTLE
KIDS BUT OUR AFTER SCHOOL
SYSTEM NEEDS AND TENSION AS
WELL- KERR. ARE ASUS PROGRAMS
ARE NOT OPEN DURING THE SUMMER
AND ON SCHOOL HOLIDAYS IT MAKES
SOME NOT VERY HELPFUL SO HOW DO
WE START TO HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE CHILD CARE
SYSTEM. THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THAT
DURATION AND ALWAYS HAPPY TO
TALK ABOUT SPECIFICS. CLEARLY
SO THANK YOU CENTER THE MONNING
HAS ANOTHER QUESTION PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CARE AND YOU
KNOW MY OTHER QUESTION IS A
SOMETIMES SOME OF THESE
OPPORTUNITIES- WE SEE
DISPARITIES REGIONAL. REGIONAL
DISPARITIES AND SO I'M
WONDERING IF ANYONE CAN SPEAK
TO PERHAPS ANY REGIONAL
DISPARITIES THAT WE MAY BE SEEN
WHETHER IT'S A PARTNERSHIP WITH
BUSINESSES WE A LOT OF COMMON
RIGHT A LOT OF TALK ABOUT THE
BAY AREA AREA. BUT WHAT WHAT
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT OTHER
REGIONS OF THE STATE THAT
SURELY STILL HAVE CHILD CARE
NEEDS- BUT WHERE THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PARTNER WITH
BUSINESS MIGHT BE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT. ANY PALACE PLEASE
FEEL FREE. THIS IS DAVID
RATTRAY- I MEAN I JUST SAY THE
OBVIOUS THING THANK YOU AGAIN
SENATOR FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS SPACE- THE OBVIOUS THING
IS WE SEE THE AREAS THAT HAVE
BEEN RESEARCH HISTORICALLY EVEN
MORE IN DISTRESS NOW SO THERE'S
GOING TO BE- ARE COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR OUR LOWEST INCOME
COMMUNITIES. WHERE WE HAVE THE
LOWEST WEALTH. AND WE HAVE THE
LEAST CAPITAL INVESTMENT AT
LEAST PRIVATE SECTOR EMPLOYMENT
LIKE YOU JUST SAID- WE HAVE THE
MOST STRESS. SO NO SURPRISE
THERE BUT IT SHOULD BE A WAKE
UP CALL AND WANT TO GO BACK TO
THIS POSSIBLY- HUGE INVESTMENT
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- WE
SHOULD DISPROPORTIONATELY MAKE
THOSE MONIES AVAILABLE TO OUR-LOWEST INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
OUR PROVIDERS IN THOSE LOWEST
INCOME COMMUNITIES. AND I KNOW
THAT'S NOT EASY BECAUSE OUR
MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES NEED
RESOURCES TO. BUT NOWHERE NEAR
THE SAME PROPORTIONALITY IT'S
NOT EVEN CLOSE SO I THINK IT'S
GONNA BE REALLY IMPORTANT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO- TO
DISPROPORTIONATELY ALLOCATE
THOSE FEDERAL ONE TIME
RESOURCES TO REBUILDING AND
SUPPORTING THE SECTOR. IN THE
LOWEST INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
MOSTLY THE COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
THAT. CHAIR AT FIVE AGENCIES.
THANK YOU ITS FIRST I WANT TO
SIT BACK AND- WITH DAVID JUST
SAID AND THEN I JUST WANT TO
ADD- WERE ACTUALLY WORKING ON
ANOTHER REPORT AND WE DID A
NATIONAL REPORT ON THE IMPACT
OF LACK OF ACCESS TO CHILDCARE
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND HOW IT'S
FURTHER DEVASTATING RURAL
COMMUNITIES BECAUSE FAMILIES
CANNOT STAY. THEY CAN'T TAKE
JOBS IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AND BECAUSE THERE
IS NO CHILD CARE AVAILABLE AND
SO I THINK YOUR POINT IS
EXACTLY THE RIGHT ONE- DIETS WE
HAVE TO INVEST IN THE AREAS-
AND- I'VE URBAN AREAS WHERE
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
UNDERSERVED SYSTEMATICALLY BUT
ALSO IN RURAL AREAS SO THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE TO STRENGTHEN OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES AND MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR FAMILIES. GROWING
UP THERE TO CONTINUE TO STAND
RAISE THEIR CHILDREN THEIR- I
APPRECIATE WHAT WE WILL LOOK
FORWARD TO RECEIVING THAT
REPORT. THAT ANY OTHER COMMENTS
IN RESPONSE FROM PANELISTS. I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A QUICK
COMMENT I THINK I THINK WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY IS GREAT BUT I THINK
WE SHOULD ALSO THINK ABOUT HOW
CAN WE EXPAND TO OTHER PUBLIC
AGENCIES PROBABLY FORM
COLLABORATIONS INSTEAD OF. YOU
KNOW HIGHER IT BEING ISOLATED
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY BEING
ISOLATED HARTLEY FARM HUMIDITY
PARTNERSHIPS- I'VE WORKED BOTH
IN WORLD CALIFORNIA IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND NOW IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA VERY DIFFERENT NEEDS
IN THE TWO AREAS AND TO COME UP
WITH ONE SYSTEM FOR. SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY VERSUS
HUMBOLDT COUNTY THEY'RE THEY'RE
DIFFERENT AND HOW DO WE GET THE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS HIGHER ED
BUSINESS. ON PROVIDERS WORK TO.
THAT'S I WOULD SAY. ALSO JUST
ADDED A AND ANOTHER ISSUE THAT
WE HAVEN'T TOUCHED ON IS THE
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FACILITIES-
YOU KNOW IN THE LAST BUDGET
THERE WAS AS A BLOCK GRANT
DEVOTED PARTICULARLY AND
SPECIFICALLY FOR FACILITIES
THAT WAS SLAPPED AND WE KNOW
THAT THEIR CHILD CARE DESERTS
NOT JUST IN TERMS AND LACK OF
SUBSIDIZED DOLLARS FOR SPACES
BUT FOR THE FACILITIES
THEMSELVES. AND SO I THINK
THAT'S ANOTHER AREA AND
INVESTMENT THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
NOT ONLY RE OPENING GRANTS FOR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS BUT BUT
OPENING GRANTS AND
RETROFITTING- FACILITIES
PARTICULARLY TO SORT OF INFANTS
AND INFANTS AND TODDLERS
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT'S WHERE
THE GREATEST NEED IS- INTO
DAVID'S POINT TO I THINK TECH
IS TAKING AN EQUITY FOCUSED
APPROACH TO THE DISTRIBUTION OF
FEDERAL AND STATE DOLLARS IS
REALLY CRITICAL. IN APPRECIATE
THAT AB ANY REMAINING COMMENTS
FROM THE PALACE BEFORE I MOVE
ON TO NEXT QUESTION. SEEING
NONE THANK YOU- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTION FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. NO WE
WILL NOW RETURN TO MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC- MISTER MODERATOR- HOW
MANY CALLERS MIGHT WE HAVE A
WAITING TO TESTIFY. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE A FEW CUED UP AT
THIS TIME. I APPRECIATE THAT
LET ME READ BASED ON THE
GENTLEMAN IF YOU DO WISH TO
COMMENT. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO THANK YOU BYE DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN COVERT
RELATING CLEAN PROCOL BECAUSE
WE SOMETIMES HAVE TO IS TO TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY- THAT IS
NOT THE CASE TODAY BUT I WOULD
ASK THAT MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
WHICH PROVIDE. THEIR TESTIMONY
AS TO LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO
APPROXIMATELY TWO MINUTES SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT- AND WITH
THAT- MISTER MODERATE IF YOU
COULD PLEASE CALL IN THE FIRST
COMMENTER I'M SORRY LET ME
START WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY I SEE NONE. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WISHING TO BUY PUBLIC
COMMENT. I SEE NINE- NOW LET'S
GO TO THE FIRST CALLER THANK
YOU. RIGHT WE WILL NOW GO TO
LINE AND. PLEASE GO AHEAD. TEN
THIRTY LIKE THAT IF YOU IF YOU
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF- YOUR
AFFILIATION WITH ANY
ORGANIZATION AND THEN YOUR
COMMENTS PLEASE. I'M LYING CAN.
YES CORRECT. I'M HEARING
FEEDBACK I WOULD LIKE A FULL
TWO MINUTES PLEASE BY ALL MEANS
PLEASE GO AHEAD I'M CALLING AS
THE WIFE OF AN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR AND I'M HEARING A
NORMAN FEEDBACK. WHY DON'T WE-
MISTER MODERATOR WHY DON'T WHY
DON'T WE- MOVE TO NEXT QUESTION
A QUICK- CALLER AND SEE IF WE
CAN'T FIX THAT BUT YOU WILL GET
A CHANCE TO SPEAK FOR THE FULL
TWO MINUTES. YEAH I WILL GET A
CHANCE TO BE. I'M SORRY ABOUT
THE FEEDBACK- I DON'T IS IT
FIXED ON YOUR END. LINE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THE NAME COLBERN REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE I
THINK THAT BUT THAT IT THANK
YOU SO MUCH HAPPINESS HERE. 16%
EIGHT AM. I LOOKING FORWARD I.
UNDERSTATE ABOUT THE- SHARE AND
NOW. IF BURKE. NUMBER STATE OUT
OF VISION OUT. HERE ALL OF THE.
IF YOU WAIT- NEED ACCESS TO
TALK ARE. REALLY LOOKING AND IF
YOU. A FAMILY- IN OUR EVENT.
BOTTOM FORGET THE REAL. ALL
WORK FOR THAT. FIFTY EIGHT
BREAKING. I'M EVERY NETWORK OUR
STATE SHOULD BE A THE LOT IN
THE ALREADY WAITED I. HMM
PROPYLENE IMPOVERISHED WE OFTEN
ABILITY IN CONTRACT HELLO CAN
YOU FIND REALLY CAREFREE IN.
FUNDING AND PRIORITY AND. YEAH
BROCCOLI THERE ARE. ALL
PERSPECTIVE I CARE HOWEVER FOR
OUR COURTS WORKING FAMILIES
ONLY PROPOSED FUNDING FOR LESS
THAN SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND BLOCK
THE CURRENT. 202-122-8600
CHILDCARE VOUCHERS PLOT FINALLY
I ASKED THAT WE CONSIDER
REVISITING HOW CALIFORNIA TREAT
THAT THE GUYS CARE WORKFORCE WE
NEED TO VALUE IN THE SAME WAY
THAT. WE HAVE DONE FOR PRIVATE
PROVIDERS. WE ARE PROVIDING
DATA AMOUNT A CHILD CARE. I
DON'T CARE PROVIDER CAN BUT
HOURS THAT'S THE THING RIAN THE
BASED ON INTENT THE PROVIDER
NUMBER KNOW WHAT TO BUY. ON
THIS POINT RIGHT NOW BEGIN IN
MY- THE EXECUTIVE ORDER SIGNED
BY GOVERNOR NEWS AND THAT
ALLOWS THEM THE DYING PROVIDERS
TO BE FUNDED FOR A LOT IS GOING
AWAY FOR MANY PROVIDERS BASED
ON THE MONEY'S RUNNING OUT. I
WILL GUARANTEE YOU THAT IF WE
CANNOT GET IMMEDIATE FUNDING TO
PAY PROVIDERS FOR THE BLOCK
HEALTH FOR A CHILD WE'RE GOING
TO LOSE MORE CHILD CARE
CAPACITY AND THIS IS AN EASY
FIX. THERE ARE MONIES AVAILABLE
IN OTHER LINE ITEMS THE ONLY
AND USE THAT THE POLITICAL WILL
IN FACT BILL BEFORE THE HARD
HIT FINALLY WE NEED TO NOT BE A
CHILD CARE THE PILOT ISSUE WE
NEED TO LOOK AT CHILD CARE THAT
DUAL GENERATIONAL POVERTY
DOCTOR HER FAMILY NOW AND THEIR
CHILDREN LATER AT THE
NECRONOMICON OPPORTUNITY FOR
EMPLOYERS. AND I'VE BEEN
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY ISSUE FOR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AYE I WOULD
URGE ALL OF THE PUBLIC.
TESTIFYING HERE TO ALSO IF YOU
COULD EMAIL YOUR TESTIMONY AS
WELL OR ANY OTHER THOUGHTS- I
WILL GIVE YOU AN EMAIL ADDRESS
S. C. P. E. R. AT S. C. N. DOT
CA DOT GOV THAT'S S. C. P. E.
R. AT S. C. N. DOT CA DOT GOV
MISTER MODERATOR IF WE COULD GO
BACK TO THE FIRST. CALLER RIGHT
NOW IF THAT'S POSSIBLE. YES
MISTER CHAIR WERE NOW GOING GO
BACK TO LINE AND- BLIND. YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN- THE
INTERFERENCE HAS DISAPPEARED
I'M GOING TO TAKE THIS AS A
GOOD SIGN I AM CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MY EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR TEACHER HUSBAND WHO
CAN'T CALL RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
HE'S BUSY. WHERE CHILDREN
SAVING THE HUMAN RACE IF YOU
WILL. AND THIS HEARING TODAY
WAS QUITE SHOCKING TO ME HI ALL
OF THIS FOR A VIRUS WITH A 99%
OVER NINETY NINE POINT 9%
SURVIVAL RATE. I'M VIRUS THAT
POSES ALMOST NO RISK TO
CHILDREN. IF YOU ASK THE LAB
COAT HOW DO YOU STOP VIRUS THAT
SPREADS THROUGH HUMAN
INTERACTION DO NOT BE SURPRISED
WHEN THEY TELL YOU. TO STOP
HUMAN INTERACTION LOCKDOWN
MASCOT KEEP YOUR DISTANCE.
YOU'RE LOGGED ON THE- NO MAN
SHALL. WE NEVER NEEDED THEM
ANYWAY. I KNOW LINE FIRST CALL
FOR ONE FOR PLAYING.
INTERMOUNTAIN GREEN AGING I
SOCIAL THOUGH I'M NOT FEAR
DRIVEN ALGORITHM. IS EVERYONE'S
BEING AND PEOPLE WHITE
SUPREMACISTS LOOTING AND- BAD
HIDING MARK. MADNESS OF
CORONADO AND STUPIDITY CDC WHL
W. E. LARA IS MASQUERADING AS
SCIENCE. SCIENCE THE STUDY WHO
WITH INPUT CREATING OUTPUT
AMPLIFIED BY AGENDA. CREATING
HYSTERIA CROWD COMPLYING WITH
THEM SURE ALWAYS I'M SORRY THE
MALL NO POLICE NEED SOCIAL
SHAME WORK JUST FINE YOUR KNOW
PRESSURE THEY DESERVE IT THEY
WON'T. MUCH BE WEIGHED BECAUSE-
NATURAL HEARD IN NINE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR- HERE TO THAT MR
MODERATOR NEXT CALL PLEASE.
MISTER KERR WILL NOW GO LINE
THIRTEEN. GOOD MORNING MY IS
LAURIE FIRST AND LEAD ELECTED
CO DIRECTOR AT THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S INTENT TO
TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION ON THE
FEDERAL FUNDING TO BRING
IMMEDIATE EMERGENCY RELIEF YOUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDER. AND THE
MANY PARENTS WHO MIGHT HAVE
CHILD CARE RIGHT NOW WELL
IMMEDIATE RELIEF IS ESSENTIAL
TO THE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE
ADMINISTERED CHILD CARE PROGRAM
WE ALSO URGE RELIEF FOR THE
PROVIDER WHO DO NOT OR CANNOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE STATE
CHILD CARE PROGRAM. THESE
PROVIDERS EARN VERY LOW WAGES
AND ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
BLACK AND BROWN WOMEN. WHILE
THEY ARE SUPPORT OTHER
BUSINESSES BY PROVIDING CARE
FOR EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
CHILDREN THEY ARE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. THOUSAND HAVE
ALREADY CLOSED AND MANY WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO RE OPEN WITHOUT
CASH RELIEF. WE ARE KEEPING OUR
CHILDREN SAFE AND HEALTHY AT
THE TIME AND ENSURING THAT
PARETS CAN WORK. WE ALSO URGE
THE IMMEDIATE ACTION MUST
INCLUDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR
FAMILY FEE FOR ALL FAMILIES
MANY OF WHOM ARE ALSO BLACK AND
BROWN MOTHER. WHO HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC THEY
CANNOT AFFORD TO PAY HUNDREDS
OF DOLLARS PER MONTH AND FAMILY
B. WE ASK THAT AWAY VERY B. E.
NOT AT THE EXPENSE OF THE CHILD
THE PROVIDERS DURING PRODUCTION
AND FEES. THANK YOU. IN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY- THIS
MODERATE IF I COULD ASK THE
MODERATORS HOW MANY COLORS DO
WE HAVE REMAINING. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO OTHER CALLERS
REMAINING AT AGAIN I'D LIKE TO
INVITE THE PUBLIC AGAIN IF YOU
HAVE NOT SPOKEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. YEAH IT WILL GIVE
THAT A MOMENT- AND MISS MATTER
WOULD YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE
ONE MORE TIME. SURE THERE IS NO
ONE ELSE WILL WISHING TO SPEAK
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU AB INTO
ANY MEMERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANY ANY LAST COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS- VERY GOOD. THEN IF
THERE NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS I
WILL CLOSE- AS I MENTIONED IN
MY OPENING REMARKS THE GOAL OF
TODAY'S HEARING WAS TO EXAMINE
SOME OF THESE ISSUES RELATED
CHILD CARE IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY IN THE SCOPE
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF THE
PANDEMIC ACROSS A WIDE VARIETY
PERSPECTIVES FROM EXPERTS AND
PARTICIPANTS IN THE FIELD AS
WE'VE HEARD AS THE BIG CAN'T
PANDEMIC PROGRESS MANY
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS FOUND
THEMSELVES CONFUSED- INDEED
WHIPSAWED BY THE FLOW OF
AMBIGUOUS AND SOMETIMES
CONTRADICTORY GUIDANCE AND
CONSTANTLY CHANGING
REQUIREMENTS EMANATING FROM THE
STATE BRINGING A SEEMINGLY
NEVER ENDING ENDING. A STRING
OF NEW RULES AND REGULATIONS.
OPERATIONS IN THE CHILDREN IN
THEIR CARE. AS YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY MANY OF THE MANY IF NOT
MOST OF THE ISSUES RAISED HERE
THIS MORNING BECAUSE CHALLENGES
TO THE CHILD CARE SECTOR. WELL
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC OF THE BEEN
DEMOCRATS ONLY SERVE TO EXPOSE
THESE ISSUES FURTHER. AS WE
MOVE TOWARD THE RE OPENING OF
K. THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS IN
THE RECOVERY OF THE ECONOMY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WORKING
PARENTS WILL NEED TO RELY ON
EXPANDED CAPACITY CHUKKER
PROVIDERSNOW MORE THAN EVER IN
THE WORDS OF JULIA MORE A CHILD
CARE OPERATOR AND THIS
MORNING'S FIRST PANEL
PARTICIPANT. CHILD CARE IS THE
BACKBONE OF THE ECONOMY IT'S
THE WORK THAT MAKES OTHER WORK
POSSIBLE. TO PUT IT ANOTHER
WAY- IN THE VERY ELEGANT WORDS
OF DYNASTY RICHARD CHILD CARE
IS IMPORTANT TO GETTING TO WORK
AS ROACH. AS A COROLLARY
BENEFIT IF WE WERE REALLY.
WILLING AND ABLE TO INVEST IN
CHILDCARE CALIFORNIA- AS MISTER
ROGERS IN THIS MAJOR POINT ON
THEIR TESTIMONY WE WOULD UNLOCK
UNTOLD BENEFITS FOR CALIFORNIA
ALONG THE WAY JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY. IMPROVING CHILD
CARE IN CALIFORNIA AND MAKING
IT MORE EQUITABLE AND
AFFORDABLE IS A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY AS WELL. THE
DOCTOR LET'S COMMENT EARLIER IN
A STATE AS VAST AND COMPLEX IS
CALIFORNIA. ONE SIZE CLEARLY
DOES NOT FIT ALL. ONE OF MY
GOALS AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON PANDEMIC
EMERGING RESPONSES TO ENSURE TO
THE MAXIMUM EXTENT POSSIBLE.
THAT THE LESSONS LEARNED HERE
ARE APPLIED BOTH AS WE MOVE
INTO THE RECOVERY PHASE OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND THE RECESSION IT
IS BECAUSE BUT JUST IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE THAT. IN THE FACE OF
THE NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY FOR A QUICK LANE YOU
CAN. ECONOMIC CRISIS IN THE
FUTURE. AND THERE SURELY WILL
BE ONE WE DON'T KNOW WHEN WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IT WILL
LOOK LIKE THAT WE KNOW WE WILL
FACE IT. THERE ARE STATE NEVER
FINDS ITSELF IS EXPOSED AND
UNPREPARED AGAIN. I'D LIKE TO
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO THANK
AND COMMEND THE COMMITTEE'S
PREVIOUS CHAIR SENATOR LINDA
GONZALEZ. GOOD WORK DONE UNDER
HER LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS TO
THANK THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS. AND COMMITMENT
AS WELL. TO TODAY'S PANEL
PARTICIPANTS WE THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THE TIME AND FOR SHARING
YOUR VERY VALUABLE INSIGHTS
WITH THE COMMITTEE TODAY. AND
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
CALLED IN TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE THIS. PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE AT. S. C. P. E. R. S.
E. N. DOTCA DOT GOV. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO USAND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
YOU AGAIN WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION ONE THAT
WE NEED TO CONTINUE RIGOROUSLY
AS WE EXPLORE SOLUTIONS. DEVICE
POLICIES IN ALLOCATE
APPROPRIATE RESOURCES TO
ENSURE. THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
PARENT AND FAMILY HAS ACCESS TO
SAFE. AFFORDABLE GEOGRAPHICALLY
CONVENIENT AND NURTURING CHILD
CARE THAT WAS SUPPORT EMPOWER
FAMILIES. WHILE ALLOWING
PARENTS TO CONTINUE
PARTICIPATING CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE. AND CONTRIBUTING TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. THANK YOU
TO EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED IN
TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS AND THANK
YOU AGAIN TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. AND YOUR COOPERATION
WITH THAT WE HAVE NOW COMPLETED
TODAY'S AGENDA. AND WE NOW
CONCLUDE TODAY'S HEARING THE
SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY RESPONSE. IS
INSURANCE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.